Hello,
my friends,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience is sponsored by stamps.com stamps.com
is an awesome way to avoid going to the post office and waiting in line you.
If you do send things online,
you know that there is a real issue with going to the post office boxing up
stuff.
If you have your own personal business,
personal business,
you have a small business,
send things out of your home.
You got to go to the post office,
bring your packages,
have them weighed out.
It's a huge time consuming pain in the ass and all that stuff can be avoided.
Now@stamps.com stamps.com allows you to print official us postage with a home
computer.
It's amazingly easy.
And uh,
with our uh,
offer,
if you use the Promo Code J R,
e Dot,
they give you a $110.
Bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55 a free postage.
All of it can be taken care of from your home.
It's so nice.
You weigh it out,
you,
uh,
you get the printer to print out the US postage,
you put it on the package,
the mailman comes,
you handed to him and you're done.
It's a beautiful,
fantastic way to increase your productivity and avoid the nonsense that is
waiting in line at the post office.
And if the rates go up,
if there's any change in postal rates,
it's all covered by stamps.com.
It's open 24 slash seven.
You can do it naked,
you can do it drunk.
Nobody could tell you to stop you.
It's a beautiful thing.
Stamps.com.
And if you go to stamps.com,
before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinjrethatstamps.com and enter
j r e for your $110 bonus offer.
It's used by Brian Red Band who just showed up,
um,
to send out the kittycat tee shirts from a desk squad dot TV.
Tom Thompson,
Christina Palicki.
They use it for your mom.
Sounds to send out their stuff.
Bert Kreischer uses it.
Stamps.com,
we can't say enough good things about it.
It's an awesome,
easy,
convenient way to send things from your home with official us postage and I'm
much more relaxing way.
We are also brought to you by lumosity.com.
Lumosity.com is essentially like an online gym for your brain.
A lot of folks don't know that you can actually train your brain the way you
train your body.
Most people think of the brain as being just some sort of an eight Oregon that
just stays the way it is.
Your,
your brain actually benefits from exercise and you can stimulate your brain
through exercises that they provide actual games@lumosity.com,
scientifically designed to train your memory,
challenge your attention and problem solving,
problem solving skills,
and they're fun.
If you go to lumosity.com,
it's a really interesting sort of setup they have there.
When you go there,
they allow you to build a personalized training program.
You Click on the get started thing and then you go right into the,
uh,
the options like memory,
remembering patterns and locations,
associating names with faces,
keeping track of multiple pieces of information,
attention,
ignoring distractions,
quickly,
picking out patterns,
speed,
decision making,
and time sensitive situations.
Quickly.
We're crawling recent information and all these things are actual things that
you can train your brain to do.
It's quite fascinating and most importantly,
it's actually fun.
So instead of just playing some candy crusher,
angry birds type game that eats away all your time and it is very addictive.
You can actually do something on lumosity.com that has a similar fun factor to
it but is actually good for your brain actually gives you exercise that can be
beneficial in real areas of your life.
And you can play lumosity from anywhere.
You can get it on an ipad or an iphone with the free lumosity app and you could
do it during your downtime and you can get away with playing games and actually
doing something beneficial.
At the same time.
You can trick yourself.
You triggered,
trick yourself into,
you know,
you're,
you're feel like you're wasting time,
but you're actually working on yourself.
And I love it.
I love the games.
I think they're fun to play and uh,
I liked the fact that it's,
it's something that's actually beneficial for your mind.
Um,
you can check out my special lumosity page to get started.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash Joe.
That's lumosity.com/Joe.
Click the start training button and start playing your first game.
It's a very fun way to work out your mind and like I said,
you kind of trick yourself because it's enjoyable.
You feel like you're not actually doing something worthwhile,
but you are lumosity.com forward slash Joe.
We are also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t,
m on it is a human optimization website.
What we sell is essentially everything that I find that I use,
whether it's strength and conditioning equipment,
whether it's a health and nutrition supplements,
whether it's foods like hemp forest,
protein bars,
or the earth grown nutrients supplement that we,
uh,
we suggested a lot of people add to your daily shakes in the morning to cover
your nutritional needs.
No Soy,
no dairy,
no gluten free,
fantastic mix of nutrients,
champion,
antioxidant blend.
We have Peruvian Purple Corn Isi,
he fruit,
all sorts of different antioxidants combined with the power green blend,
which is Spirulina,
Alfalfa,
old grass,
Kale and more.
All this stuff is available.
The information behind the is all available at [inaudible] dot com and it all is
quite fascinating and it's really,
really healthy stuff.
And a great way to cover your bases.
We would all like to get all of our nutrients from food if and whenever
possible.
And if you're a guy like Joel Salatin,
you can do that.
But if you're a guy out there on the move and maybe perhaps a mixing in some not
so healthy food with,
uh,
with,
you know,
fresh fruits and vegetables and lean meats and proteins,
sometimes you,
uh,
you need to supplement and one of the best ways to stop them.
And is this earth grown nutrients package.
Everything we sell it on it is stuff that either I use or Aubrey uses my,
um,
my partner in on it and things that we have found that we have researched and
things that we have found that there's science behind it.
If you go to any of the products like especially the things like Alpha brain,
which is a cognitive enhancing nutritive nutritional combination of things that
have all been shown to benefit memory with a nootropic is for folks who don't
not familiar with the term nootropics,
are essentially nutrients that are,
that have been found to enhance cognitive function.
And what that means is the all the building blocks for human neurotransmitters
to building blocks and enhance your memory.
It can be very confusing,
but if you go to [inaudible] dot com and click on the Alpha brain link,
there's actually a bunch of science behind it,
a bunch of research behind it,
uh,
with references.
We actually have done our own clinically based a double blind placebo study and
those results are available at [inaudible] dot com and more studies are ongoing.
It's all really fascinating stuff.
Cutting edge nutrition and um,
controversial in a sense,
but noncontroversial in the fact that we give you a 100 percent money back
guarantee.
Ninety days on the first 30 pills,
you have a 100 percent money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return your product.
He just have to say this stuff's bullshit.
And uh,
then you get your money back.
That's crazy.
I didn't know that a is going naked or not having like the colored pills anymore
because they're getting rid of the dyes and stuff.
That's actually on the pills.
Yeah,
yeah.
We did that a while ago.
But um,
it's also because people like,
they look like when you look at it,
it looks like a,
well,
yeah.
Well Green.
And it was green and yellow and it doesn't look like ecstasy.
It looks like I'm like a pharmaceutical,
you know,
it looks like something that you would get.
It doesn't look like earth grown nutrients.
It doesn't look like it's healthy.
I Dunno.
Just colors,
gelatin,
gelatin and colors.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com.
Use the code word Rogan and save 10 percent off any and all supplements.
I alluded yesterday that we've got some big news coming out.
It's going to be awhile before announced it,
but we have big plans at,
on it in.
I can't tell you too much about it,
but uh,
it'll be,
uh,
about um,
about uh,
mixed martial arts is what it's going to be about.
And it's going to be about,
um,
I'll just tell you it's about training center.
Alright,
there it is.
That's it on a Dotcom.
Use a codeword Rogan.
Save 10 percent off any and all supplements.
Joel Salitan is here and we're going to talk to him and we're going to learn
some shit.
The Joe Rogan experience
podcast by night.
A sure sign,
sir,
that we live in a mad,
mad world is when a person has seen ideas and he comes across as a revolutionary
and I have Joel Saltz and for folks who don't know as an American farmer or
lecture or you're an author and your approach to farming is,
it's so natural and so normal.
And so,
uh,
in my opinion noncontroversial that it's,
it's quite fascinating that in this day and age with this mad,
mad world of factory farming and pumping these animals full of hormones and
chemicals and antibiotics,
that your approach has sort of revolutionized a lot of the ideas that people
have about farming.
I think it's a real sign that there's something wrong with us.
When I watch your methods and I've seen your videos and I've heard you talk on
it,
it seems like no nonsense.
It seems like it seems normal.
It seems like common sense,
it seems like old knowledge,
but yet you're looked at as some sort of a wild man out there.
A lunatic.
You're a lunatic.
You're nice to your animals.
Yeah,
we are.
I mean,
you know,
people say,
Oh,
you're so clever,
you know,
how do you come up with this?
And My response is that,
uh,
this is not new,
you know,
uh,
I mean it takes,
like take just for example,
our culture,
right?
I mean our,
our experts,
you know,
our Usda and are a usda,
our expert tea.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
they don't think that animals are supposed to move.
I mean,
but animals are supposed to move.
I mean that's like,
that's like a fundamental,
natural pattern.
And so yeah,
if you pause it,
oh,
animals were supposed to move will then a whole series of things happen,
you know,
from,
control mechanisms,
shelter,
you know,
water delivery systems,
all sorts of things happen to happen.
If you just pause it,
something as,
as intuitively simple as on our farm,
animals are going to move.
It's amazing.
So you know,
if animals are going to move,
you have to keep them home,
you have to be able to move them in the right place at the right time.
So then you have to have portable control mechanisms or you got to keep them
comfortable.
So then you have portable shade mechanisms and uh,
you got to u of m water,
so we've got to be able to have portable water and um,
and so all these things necessarily flow from just something as basic as animals
move.
Find it fascinating.
It is fascinating because most people have,
they've,
they've gone the opposite way with what they've said is we don't want animals to
move.
So let's contain it.
Right?
Right.
I mean,
so the,
the industrial system is predicated on,
you know,
we,
we lock all these animals up in a,
in a confinement facility,
a 15,000 chickens in a house,
you know,
non laying hens and a 16 by 22 inch cubicle.
Uh,
I mean there's not enough room even to sit down cattle in feedlots,
pigs in confinement houses.
And we'd do the same thing kind of in our plants.
I mean,
that's the next thing then is in nature,
there are no monocultures,
there are no monitor species.
Anywhere you go in nature,
no matter where you'd hike,
there's going to be at least two species.
You're going to encounter multiple things.
In fact,
you're going to counter animals and plants in proximity.
Amazing.
It's not going to be fields of animal lists,
wheat or fields of animalistic strawberries.
And then over here the animals can find in a,
you know,
a little itty bitty building,
stinking up the neighborhood instead in nature.
These things are actually proximate and they're actually symbiotic.
I mean,
they actually have a lot of synergistic functions to each other.
I found it fascinating that you w when you raise your pigs,
you,
you call them a wood finish,
forest finished.
Yeah.
We call them a,
you know,
a pasture finished or,
or acorn.
Glen's a,
we call them Glen's,
you know,
for the old leprechauns,
lurking in the plan and the forest just has a nice ring to it.
But uh,
yeah,
we,
we use electric fence.
This is not,
you know,
a luddite.
This is not anti technology stuff.
What we're doing is using pigs.
All pigs have four wheel drive and uh,
uh,
they,
they like to disturb places.
I mean,
you know,
they have a great big bow on the end of their face called the nose and so all
we're doing is taking the way buffalo and fire and predators used to move across
the landscape with this,
you know,
with periodic disturbance.
We don't have buffalo anymore,
we don't have the fire,
we don't have the wolves much.
And so how do we create this disturbance,
you know,
this is a,
this is a very important ecological principle that,
um,
that living organisms have to be disturbed in order to have succession to
another level.
You know,
whether it's the pain that comes from a exercise and if you want to,
if you want to be physically fit,
you got to disturb your body,
you got to get up off the couch.
Potato and ecology is the same way.
It needs to be disturbed.
And so,
you know,
actually the ecology is used to having a lot of disturbance factors on it,
disturbance and then rest disturbance.
And then rest,
and so we use high tech electric fencing to be able to move these pigs around in
these forests.
Glen's from one little section to another in a,
in a kind of rapid rotation so that we have very,
um,
intense disturbance and then a long period of rest in intense disturbance and
long fraser.
And what that does is the pigs then go in and they,
they till they eat bugs that would affect the trees.
They route out starchy weedy species,
things like that.
And um,
eat a lot,
eat a lot of goodies to get fresh air.
They get exercise,
sunshine and a and are able to fully express their pigness and uh,
and,
and what you end up within is an incredibly nutrient dense product as opposed to
a white meat,
flabby product like out of the industry.
And the other thing is that you now have a whole new bunch of species that have
germinated and sprouted in this disturbed a environment is disturbed soil.
And you actually,
you actually capture more solar energy than you would with just leaves and
sterile forest bottom.
So the,
the actual product,
that pig itself would be more like a wild pig then?
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
In fact,
we've had a,
we supply about 50 restaurants and um,
we've had chefs do displacement tests where they'll get like industry p,
industry,
pork,
and our pork,
and using their very carefully calibrated scales they can make,
you know,
two blocks of meat that are exactly the same weight,
put them in a pan of water,
measure the displacement and our pork displaces less water per pound than the
industrial park.
What does that mean?
Well,
what it means is that the tissue is stronger.
In other words,
there is,
there is more weight per cubic inch,
which,
which means it's,
it's better formed.
It's why would we call that?
We call that muscle tone.
Oh,
I see,
I see.
So they're denser fat,
fat,
and Flab.
We can say Flab,
um,
is,
is a lot more volume per pound.
If you jump into a swimming pool and you're really muscled,
toned,
sometimes you have trouble floating.
But if you're a,
you know,
a fat person,
you can float in atwater water like a blimp all day,
you know,
it just works fine.
And so,
so,
you know,
a density,
muscle tone and density can be measured with a displacement tests.
That's fascinating.
So I'm this much more nutrient dense.
Absolutely.
Is,
is,
is it preferred by these chefs?
Oh,
absolutely.
I mean that's why.
That's why they get it.
And the end result is that you actually get,
you actually get more nutrition per pound because it's,
you know,
it's denser.
I smoked a wild hand for the first time this past week and it was a fascinating
how much different it tasted than a regular ham.
So your,
your Hams would be similar to that,
right?
That's right.
Darker,
yeah.
Uh,
you know,
when the industry says pork,
remember they had the campaign for what,
10 years,
pork,
the other white meat.
I think now it's um,
what's the new that they abandoned that slogan,
now it's a,
uh,
something like,
you know,
get with it or something like that.
Be inspired,
be inspired by it.
That's exactly what,
being an animal that lives in a box.
How,
what?
Yeah.
So,
so,
uh,
disease that.
Yeah.
So you know,
my,
my father in law,
he's in his eighties now and you know,
they used to raise hogs on their farm and it's interesting they built there.
They had a kind of a shed shelter where the pigs would go in and eat like sour
milk and whey and leftovers from the milk about 20 cows.
And so they'd always be leftovers.
And the pigs go in there.
Well they actually built it with the sil two feet above the ground so the pigs
had to jump up in there and that exercise made their hams taste way better and
it,
and it increased oxygen flow to their hands.
So the meat was rose colored rather than white.
And that,
and that rose color indicates iron,
hemoglobin,
iron.
So the,
the exercise of jumping in and the extra eye.
I collect old ag books.
Anything before 19 fifties,
pretty good.
After that it all went to pot.
And uh,
and so if you read any like old 19,
10,
19,
20,
1900 a swine book,
the first thing it'll say is exercise exercise because the pork responds to that
oxygenation of the blood and makes the meat a deep,
a deep rich color,
which indicates,
you know,
iron
that is so fascinating.
So this white meat is pork,
the other white.
What a crazy ad campaign that is.
Of course it is based entirely on,
on,
on ignorance.
Sure it is.
Yes it is.
I mean,
the same thing as,
you know,
our chickens are vegetarians.
It's ridiculous.
Birds are omnivores.
No,
I mean whoever saw robin refuse a worm,
you know,
I mean birds are omnivores.
So this whole idea of,
of a vegetarian fed chickens is just,
doesn't be sick chickens.
Yeah,
it,
it makes you know,
Pale nutrition,
nutrient deficient egg.
Yeah.
There's a big difference in the color of the eggs.
I have chickens,
I have 13 chickens in my yard and my wife and I have been doing that for the
past year and a half now.
And it's amazing how much better the eggs taste.
It's amazing how much darker the Yolk is,
it's like a dark orange and uh,
you know,
we have a big yard and we keep them and we have a huge house built that's bigger
than the studio,
bigger than this room at least,
and the chickens all live in there and they have plenty of room to run around.
And then Taj Mahal chicken house,
it's a big chicken house and then we opened the door and let them roam around
the yard and pick up bugs and worms and all that stuff.
But they're chicken this expressed.
That's a good way to.
That's a good way to put it in our,
in our country right now,
in the industrial foods,
I call it the,
uh,
the industrial corporate USDA fraternity,
they don't view life as fundamentally biological.
They view life as fundamentally mechanical.
That's the big difference between the industrial food perspective and what I'll
call a,
a more,
um,
a craft oriented food perspective.
Is,
is food fundamentally biological or is it mechanical and they don't ask.
I mean,
I've never seen a research project that starts with an umbrella,
a supposition.
Um,
let's,
let's define what makes a happy chicken or a happy pig,
you know,
it's all about how do we grow them faster,
fat or bigger,
cheaper,
and uh,
as if they're just inanimate piles of protoplasm ics structure to be
manipulated.
However,
cleverly Hubris can imagine to manipulate them.
And I would suggest that a culture that views it's food,
it's plant and an animals from,
from that kind of mechanistic,
manipulative standpoint,
we'll view its people the same way that other cultures the same way.
That's a very good point.
Both points.
Yeah.
Is a very good point.
Do you think that your,
your,
your style of farming is,
is that possible on a large scale?
That's my favorite question.
Uh,
know can we feed the world because ultimately all of this is just a bunch of,
is an exercise in,
uh,
you know,
feel goodness,
warm fuzziness unless it actually does translate to feeding the world.
So let,
let,
let's take that and interrupt me anytime.
I'm first of all,
for the first time in human history,
we're producing twice as much human edible food as we need on the planet twice a
manage half of all human edible food never gets eaten by a human.
That's the first time that's ever happened,
which means,
which means that if,
if you were,
I could click our fingers today and suddenly double the earth's food production,
not a single other person would get a meal.
Food people go hungry.
Not because there's not enough food,
but because of demographic problems,
infrastructure problems,
you know,
there's not a road,
um,
you know,
uh,
um,
cultural issues like in inner cities and,
you know,
that had been taken over by drugs,
may have an and,
and gangs,
uh,
businesses don't want to go there.
You know,
people with integrity,
food don't want to go there.
And so,
and so there's a,
uh,
there's a tremendous amount of waste.
I mean,
I was talking to a guy that just was at a green bean factory in Zimbabwe.
They were exporting to Europe and they were taken in five tons a day and only
shipping to tons.
I says,
what happened to us in three tons?
Well,
they're crooked,
they're too long,
they're too short,
they've got a little black spot that you know.
And um,
so,
you know,
so we're,
we're waste,
we're wasting a lot of food.
Secondly,
there is a tremendous amount of land that's not being used because we have a
fundamentally segregated food system,
not an integrated food system.
So we,
you know,
we produce the food over here,
but we,
and we eat it over here.
We feed it over here.
We have the manure over here,
you know,
the,
the old integrated system is no longer,
there are $35,
million acres of lawn in the US and $36 million acres housing and feeding
recreational horses.
That 71 million acres,
that's enough to feed the entire us without a single farmer ranch.
Wow.
So what this food that's going bad.
So if we're making twice as much food as people need,
what is it?
A matter of the food deteriorating too quickly to get to people or it's never
going to get to people.
It's never going to get to people,
uh,
you know,
go,
go by the back door of any supermarket produce department and you will see,
you know,
dumpsters full of spoil stuff at one of the reasons.
I mean,
there are numerous reasons.
There are,
there are residue problems,
for example,
you know,
a dairy that,
that accidentally dumped some antibiotic for example.
And then it takes a whole tractor trailer load of milk that's common,
that's common.
Um,
you have a cosmetic issues,
you know,
a piece of fruit that has one little blemish throwaway,
um,
the,
the long,
the long warehousing and chain of custody,
uh,
between,
you know,
between field and fork that create spoilage issues.
And so,
you know,
there are just a lot of factors in the system that don't do it,
that,
that spoiled food.
That being said,
um,
we,
we can absolutely grow a lot more food than we do.
Um,
people are enamored,
you know,
they see six combines running side by side down through a Kansas wheat field and
say,
wow,
look at that,
you know,
or they see a great big,
a 500 acre fumigated strawberry field in California,
you know,
wow,
look at all that production.
But the fact is that even a very rudimentary,
almost poorly done backyard garden is more productive per square yard than the
most industrial sophisticated,
technologically advanced Monto speciated industrial farm.
That's the truth.
Why is that?
Why is that is because there is a,
when you,
when you diversify,
when you have a diversified,
a cornucopia of plants and animals in proximity,
you actually have a synergistic effect so that instead of growing one species,
if you reduce the production of one species and grow to species on the same
area,
um,
you get like 120 percent of your production.
So for example,
you know,
we,
we have pastured livestock,
so we run the cows across the pasture.
We run the egg mobiles behind them,
the egg mobiles,
or have chickens that scratch to the cow patties and eat the eat now the newly
exposed grasshoppers and crickets that the,
uh,
that the cows exposed by eating the grass.
And then we run broiler chickens,
meat chickens over that same ground.
We run turkeys over that same ground.
And so all of those animals,
they're not on the same square foot at the same time,
but they go like,
uh,
you know,
like,
uh,
um,
different waves of,
of production across the landscape.
And so whereas the normal farm would have only one of those species confined in
a little tiny building.
We have an acre being used all throughout the year with a lot of different kinds
of species going across.
Suddenly you don't have pathogens if suddenly you don't have the pathogens
because of the pathogens are confused because you know,
the cow,
the cow pathogen hatches out next to a chicken pathogen and,
or you know,
and they're toxic to each other.
And so they,
they have a war in a fight and a die the cancel each other out.
Which is really what's supposed
to happen in nature.
Absolutely.
And so you know,
the kind of diversity you see on the Serengeti in Africa at a,
at a waterhole,
in,
in
Zimbabwe,
whatever.
I mean those kinds of diversities.
A,
they protect the animals from path,
from their own pathogens because almost all pathogens are species specific.
So if you put multiple diversity together,
it,
it acts as a,
as a dead end.
Okay.
But secondly,
those animals occupy different spaces.
You know,
you've got,
you've got herbivores,
omnivores carnivores,
you know,
there are all occupying the same space.
And so a given area can stack.
That's a permaculture concept.
If you're familiar with permaculture,
can stack synergistic multiple species and enterprise on a single land base.
Brian,
pull up a polyface farms.
There's a,
there's a video,
fascinating videos,
so you can,
the folks at home can get a sense of what he's talking about when he's saying
egg mobiles and you've designed this sort of chicken house that moves around.
It's,
it's on sleds,
it's all wheels and you pull it around and so the chickens will be in one spot
and then you move it to another spot and in doing so you allow the land to get
moved around.
That's right.
Rather than rather than having a stationary structure where we're carrying
everything in and carrying everything out,
and there's a toxicity buildup with the animals being confined to one spot all
the time.
Instead you are actually allowing the animals to move to mimic kind of their
migratory pattern on a domestic scale.
All we're doing is we're cutting out the natural,
the natural template and,
and laying it down on a domestic production model.
Say,
how can we duplicate this,
this,
this pattern on a domestic model.
That's what,
that's what we're doing.
And in doing so in like,
this is such a large scale,
um,
can this be duplicated like the factory farming systems that are so rightly
criticized in this country,
which we find to be a born.
When you look at these videos of these chickens living stacked next to each
other,
it's,
it's horrific stuff.
It is w,
what is it that's beneficial about those factory farms that keeps them from
doing something like this?
What you have to understand is that those factory farms externalize a lot of
their costs.
So there's,
there's collateral damage of that collateral damage in terms of water pollution,
fecal particulate in the air.
One of the biggest ones right now is c diff and Murcia,
you know,
these,
um,
antibiotic resistant,
high,
uh,
high pass staph infections in hospitals and you know,
that people are getting,
um,
and,
and now of course,
you know,
we're seeing an exponential growth in autism.
There's a,
there's a link there to,
for example,
genetically modified organisms.
That might be another discussion,
but,
but the,
what I'm getting at is that the collateral damage of the industrial food system,
including the nutrient deficiency,
the fact that the Omega sixes and Omega threes are way out of whack.
So the fats,
instead of reducing cholesterol or instead of being beneficial or are negative.
Um,
there are,
there are huge nutrient deficiencies.
I mean,
Riboflavin,
the eggs in your backyard,
chickens are probably in the area of a thousand micrograms per egg.
You know what the official us Da,
you know,
nutrient analysis for exit is only 48 micrograms per eggs,
cheese and,
and you know,
and um,
I'm sorry,
not a folic acid.
Folic acid,
grass finished beef,
a 300 percent more riboflavin.
A Riboflavin of course is what helps us to keep calm and not fly off the handle.
It's a,
it's the nerve.
Riboflavin is the nerve one.
Uh,
you know,
why are people raging and going crazy and you know,
shooting people in schools and stuff.
Um,
because we're,
we're deficient in Riboflavin.
So,
you know,
when,
when people say all yeah,
it doesn't make any different food is food,
is food.
That's not true.
I mean there's a huge difference in this food.
Um,
you know,
vegetables the same way whether they're grown in,
mineral dense biologically active soil compared to hydroponic or just,
you know,
what we call a ivy soil,
where the soil is just inert material to hold up a route.
And we,
we basically ivy chemical fertilizers into that soil to grow up,
you know,
to grow a plant.
So there are,
there are,
there are significant differences in the nutritional element.
So this is all collateral damage and,
and,
and the slinky effect between cause and effect.
It takes awhile.
I mean,
take ddt,
DDT,
it took 14 years from its initial use until 14 years later.
It was definitively discovered,
oh,
that's why we have three legged salamanders,
infertile frogs and dead zones and eagles' eggs,
eggs won't hatch,
you know,
those,
cause and effects took a while to materialize because nature is pretty
resilient,
you know,
you can,
you can beat yourself up for awhile and you know,
still come out kicking for awhile.
And I'm sure there's probably also a financial factors that were resisting the
conclusions will exactly the,
all of that.
Collateral damage is deferred expense,
you know,
whether it's obesity,
health,
healthcare,
um,
pollution,
clean up a super fund sites,
you know,
soil loss,
aquifer depletion,
um,
desertification,
these are all differ damages because in our country we don't have an accounting
system to measure.
I mean,
our only accounting system is,
is,
um,
cash,
you know,
gross domestic product,
today's output.
We don't have a way to measure
these other elements.
I mean,
I'll give you,
I'll give you one example.
Let's take,
let's take a earthworms.
Let's agree that earthworms are pretty important.
Well,
you know,
who presents a business plan today to,
uh,
to an investor and the investor says,
Hey,
I kinda liked this business plan.
I think this is a good idea.
We're going to,
can I be your partner?
We're going to be millionaires,
you know,
on this,
uh,
on this business.
But,
but before I sign my investment strategy,
I've got one question for you.
I mean,
I'm from the south,
so,
you know,
got to have a big hog.
Okay?
Um,
so,
but I gotta ask you one question.
Oh,
what's this business going to do to the earthworms in our community?
Nobody asks that,
never.
Nobody has.
And,
and yet,
fundamentally,
the micro Rhizobia,
the earthworms,
the,
the Aza,
bacteria,
bacteria that mycelium the hydro,
you know,
um,
they actually this,
this invisible community of beings actually supports all of life.
What we see,
you know,
every,
every visible thing that we see is supported by an invisible universe of
microscopic bacteria and beings in us around us,
in the soil,
the cousins,
and now we know they talk to each other,
so in a sense what we're getting with factory farming is one small unit in the
environment,
extracting money at the expense of all these other factors and these extraneous
costs aren't,
aren't factored in.
That's because they don't have to be.
They don't have to be at our.
Our system is not set up for accounting.
Those other things.
Thanks.
That's fascinating.
So if,
if it was done correctly,
it was all done your way,
although would be more expensive.
Those external expenses wouldn't exist in,
in,
in the big scheme of things.
In the big scheme of things,
the actual,
the actual cost of food would actually be cheaper because you wouldn't have the
collateral damage.
I mean,
just take one example.
In our lifetime mad cow disease.
I mean,
really for 30 years,
the European and the American expert credential,
you know,
phd academic community took farmers like me to free steak dinners to teach us
this new scientific method of feeding dead gals to cows.
And our farm was branded a barbarian,
Luddite,
anti progressive,
you know,
science haters because we didn't buy into that,
uh,
that model.
The reason we didn't buy into it,
not because we were anti science or anti innovation or anything like that
because I looked around the earth and,
you know,
I couldn't find an herbivore that eats carry on.
Yeah.
I couldn't find it.
And so we said,
well,
there must be a reason.
And,
and,
and here,
30 years later,
suddenly there's this big global collective,
oops,
maybe we should not have done that,
you know,
as the whole scientific community realized,
what had happened.
And so,
uh,
so I just think there's a,
that we have to appreciate that we are in western culture.
You know,
we're a,
we're a product of,
you know,
Grieco,
Roman,
western,
reductionist,
compartmentalized,
fragmented,
systematized,
individualized,
a democratized parts oriented,
disconnected thinking.
And there's an equally appropriate,
a mindset from the east,
which is,
we're all connected,
we're all relatives.
It's about holes,
you know,
it's about us,
not just me.
And that brings us an ethical framework as a,
as a,
as a protection over all moral innovation.
You know,
we're so clever.
We can innovate things that we can't spiritually,
morally,
ethically,
or physically metabolize.
And so what happens is we innovate these things and then,
and then spend,
you know,
two generations trying to remediate,
remediate the collateral damage that are innovations did.
And if we would just embrace that there is,
there should be a moral,
ethical,
uh,
um,
natural pattern
that restricts,
that constrains our innovation.
Then our innovation could actually be kept on a,
you know,
on an earth massaging tract track instead of an earth conquistador track.
So you used to literally get courted to feed dead cows to cows like,
oh,
absolutely.
A free seminars,
you know,
come out and uh,
they've got sponsors,
you know,
the logo,
agribusiness community and uh,
uh,
you know,
the industrial,
the,
uh,
food and you know,
the industrial complex would,
would,
you know,
buy dinner and,
and you'd go here,
these,
you know,
these couple phds from the taxpayer funded research universities,
what was their motivation?
Well,
I don't understand why they faster,
bigger,
cheaper,
faster it cheap,
you know,
I mean,
it's cheap.
It's cheap protein to cheap,
cheap food,
but the,
but the idea of making your cows cannibals.
Well,
yeah.
I mean,
well,
the industry's still feeds chicken manure.
I mean,
well we're still feeding in this country right now as we sit here.
We're still feeding chicken feathers manure and chicken carcasses to chicken.
They're doing it right in our neighborhood.
Uh,
so that's still being done.
So we're still feeding but not but at least,
but at least it's not cows,
at least knockout.
But yeah,
it,
it's completely absurd.
Why is it better to do with chickens and cows will supposedly it's not the same
kind of tissue.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
so it's,
it's at least it's one species removed,
you know,
so you have some,
you have a little bit of wiggle room for the,
for the rogue prions that create the bovine spongiform encephalopathy and that's
the same disease that these cows getting mad cow disease,
the cannibals get and like in New Guinea,
these neurological disease where they can try on's.
Yeah.
[inaudible].
It punches holes in your brain.
Yeah.
It's a pretty uh,
it's a pretty bad way to go.
It seems pretty dark.
When did factory farming start?
Like the,
what we consider today factory farming?
When did all that start?
Yeah,
well,
it's a great question and it really started in the thirties,
forties and fifties.
I'm,
a lot of things had to come together and of course,
you know,
Michael Pollan in his,
uh,
I think omnivore's dilemma,
um,
examined this pretty nicely,
but to point out that or Eric Schlosser and fast food nation,
you know,
that was a blockbuster,
when it came out and a lot of factors had to be in place.
One was we had to have cheap energy because prior to,
in order to have a factory farm,
you have to have cheap transportation in order to bring in order to concentrate
that many beings in one place and feed them and remove their excrement.
You have to have cheap transportation.
Cheap transportation,
uh,
requires cheap energy.
You know,
when everything was draft power,
mules and horses and oxen,
you simply couldn't amalgamate that many things,
whether it was animals or shoes or,
or metal,
uh,
you couldn't amalgamate that much material in,
in,
in one place.
So,
so every manufacturing facility,
whether it was a farm or you know,
other manufacturing had to nest within the carrying capacity of its ecological
womb,
if you will.
There was a,
there was a limit,
how far can we cart stuff in and how far can we cart stuff out.
There was a limit to that until we had cheap energy and cheap transportation.
So that really catapulted this.
Then the next thing we had to have,
we had to have people water,
we had to have.
So,
so that meant plastic piping.
We had to have very cheap piping.
I mean,
until then it was all cast iron pipe,
you know,
in the 18 hundreds,
it was,
you know,
took a piece of wood and took an Auger and boarded out,
and,
and pasted little pipes together.
So we had to have a plastic,
so plastic had to be developed,
which of course required petroleum.
So petroleum was really a catalyst.
And then finally,
in order to keep that many animals alive in one spot required antibiotics
because the fecal particulate,
the fecal dust cloud that they live in,
that they ingest is very abrasive to the very tender,
um,
mucus,
respiratory membranes,
all the Caelian,
those,
those very,
um,
you know,
you look at them under a microscope and it's,
it's like a,
it's like going into a Steven Spielberg set,
you know,
it's just amazing.
Well,
those very tender mucous membranes
get sandpaper by this,
um,
fecal particulate,
this a brace of air and they bleed then.
And this is how Salmonella and in some of these things get into the,
into the actual tissue,
even into the eggs.
Remember the Wisconsin farm with the Salmonella,
it actually gets into the oviduct because now the old the bodies,
um,
toxic hedges,
you know,
filters,
it's strainers,
have been overridden by this,
um,
you know,
by this direct hemorrhaging of the tinder mucous membranes,
it gets right into the bloodstream.
So that's how it,
you know,
it,
it jumps those regular,
um,
uh,
strainers.
And so,
so the antibiotics were necessary to try to,
uh,
in order to keep the animals in such an unsterile,
an unhealthy environment to keep them alive.
I don't know whether you've watched just lately what's happened with pigs.
I'm Jay.
It's been all over the newspapers and Wall Street Journal even,
you know,
when you see pig futures at Wall Street Journal,
something's going on.
And uh,
I think it was in January and February,
they almost doubled.
What's the problem?
Starting April one last year,
just April one last year.
So we're,
we're,
we're literally 12 months into this exactly 12 months,
the industry started losing one in four piggies industrywide to a viral
diarrhea.
Now,
my joke is,
you know,
if there's one thing worse than diarrhea,
it's got to be viral diarrhea,
but,
but anyway,
um,
this,
this is attacking the industrial pigs.
We're not seeing it out in the countryside and pastured pigs and are sort of
things,
but it's making a pork futures skyrocket.
The industry is on it's heels.
They're desperate to find a,
find a cure.
Of course,
you know,
finding a cure would mean changing their model,
but of course they're,
they're trying to find a technological cure,
you know,
some more potent concoction.
Alright,
to knock this out in such an,
an unhealthy environment.
And so imagine that,
I mean,
nationwide,
of all the whatever,
millions of pigs,
one in four,
25 percent of all piggies right now being born in the US are dying from viral
diarrhea.
That's incredible.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a big deal,
big deal.
This environment that you're talking about,
this pathogen enriched environment where they're,
they're the fetal particulates in the air,
completely not natural in nature.
There are wide open fields in the EHR and the natural environment filters all of
this.
Is this something that's completely been over the last,
you know,
less than 100 years now?
It's very recent.
It's only in the last,
you know,
50 to 60 years.
Uh,
our rule of thumb is that a good food production,
good farming,
good food production should be aesthetically and aromatically.
Sensually romantic,
you know,
I mean,
look,
if you've got a walk through sheep dip and put on a hazmat suit to go visit your
food,
you might not want to eat it.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Now this,
this idea of factory farming,
this,
this huge large scale thing where you're stuffing all these chickens into,
could,
could those farms be converted to a more holistic approach like you're,
you're prescribing.
That is such a great question.
And,
and I'll tell you the truth.
My heart goes out to farmers who have signed on the dotted line and,
and,
and been kind of taken in by this,
by this model,
but the fact is they are so anti nature that I don't see a retrofit a.
and that's one of the problems when you have capital intensive infrastructure,
when you have single,
single designed or single use capital intensive infrastructure,
even when it becomes a detriment to society to have that infrastructure,
we still have to use it because we're economically and emotionally vested in it.
You know,
our toys run our thinking.
Um,
I mean,
look,
look at,
look at the health field.
I mean,
you know,
we have to use our infrastructure because it's really expensive and so we've got
to use this stuff.
And the same thing is true in farming.
Now,
you know,
when you pour that much concrete and bend that much rebar,
uh,
you know,
you,
you feel compelled to use it.
So it's a,
it's a real problem.
And um,
and I just,
um,
yeah,
I just don't see really efficient ways of retrofitting a lot of these
structures.
Uh,
you know,
they might make good miniature golf courses.
They might,
you know,
mail though.
God.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I mean,
just to give you,
to give you an example of some things that can be done with a different model.
One is,
just to give you an example,
one is that if you go to a composting betting in a,
in a,
in an operation,
um,
you can ameliorate a lot of the problems.
The problem is that that takes a lot of carbon.
In order to have compost,
you have to have a carbon nitrogen ratio that somewhere in the neighborhood of
25 to 35 to one.
All right can,
it's called the CN ratio.
And of course you have to have,
you have to have a moisture,
you have to have air and you have to have microbes.
So there's five components to a mike to a compost pile,
but you have to have one other thing and that is enough size to support an
internal community of microbial beings.
And Yeah,
they've got to have their,
you know,
TV shows.
I got to build their roads,
have their schools,
you know,
and I have banks and politicians and stuff too.
So it,
it takes room for these microorganisms to build those communities.
You can't build.
A compost pile is 12 inches by 12 inches by 12 inches.
Too small.
The smallest size is like a yard by yard,
by yard.
All right,
well,
the problem is that in most you know a factory farming facilities,
you can not only can you not even have any bedding in or the animals are on
slatted floors or virtually a note concrete there.
There is no life.
There is no community of beings,
good community of beings in nature.
A lot of people don't realize there are a lot more good bacteria than bad
bacteria.
There really aren't that many bad bacteria in nature.
You know,
if you're keeping score of,
of of things,
there actually a lot more good ones than bad ones.
When you come to this invisible world of little microbial beings and and so the
default position,
what I'm getting to is the default position of nature,
his health.
We in our culture right now,
we've got things so out of whack that we just assume that the default position
of nature is sickness.
Nature's broken and I've got to fix it.
That's not true.
The default position of nature is wellness and health.
If if their sickness then then that indicates something out of whack.
There's a,
there's,
there's a,
there's a protocol has been violated.
So one of the ways to house animals,
at least temporarily in shelter,
is to have a living,
a living,
um,
blanket,
I call it a carbonaceous diaper for them to live on a that is deep enough and
alive enough with all these microbes so that Neba toads attack the pathogenic
microbes.
So that,
uh,
in this,
in this sphere,
there's enough,
um,
community of beings interacting in this war of good bugs and bad bugs.
The good bugs beat out the bad bugs.
That's,
that's the right position.
And that can be done.
And we actually used that when we feed hay in the winter time in our hay shed,
we use it for the pigs in the winter when they're in housing for the,
for the brooder house where we start chicks,
we,
you know,
we have it where we can build up 24 inches of bedding in the hay shed with the
cows.
We can go four feet deep with this carbonaceous living,
composting a bedding and um,
and you know,
and,
and that is a partial answer,
but the buildings that are currently designed can't handle a living,
compost medium for the animals to be on their street.
They're structurally not designed to handle that.
And so,
you know,
the retrofit becomes pretty tough.
That's fascinating.
So it's almost like they need to be destroyed and it needs to be start from
scratch.
Yeah.
And,
and,
uh,
the beautiful thing is really they don't need to be replaced with very much.
They just need to be abandoned.
Most,
you know,
most,
most great breakthroughs throughout history.
Breakthroughs have been break widths.
Something.
Think about the breakthrough for,
for example,
um,
compact discs.
You know,
the Germans tried to do it for a long time,
but they couldn't get past the long play disk model,
you know,
uh,
that we just can't do it in the Japanese who didn't have a history of LP records
like Germany did.
They said,
well,
why does it have to be,
you know,
this size,
let's make it smaller.
Boom.
Japanese owned,
you know,
that whole market,
uh,
so it was a break with tradition and many innovations,
many innovative things.
Our break widths,
that's the key to the breakthrough.
There's a lot of,
a lot of
people that don't realize that what we're dealing with when you're talking about
a lot of the flues and a lot of the diseases that become pandemics,
that they start with livestock,
avian flu,
swine flu,
some of the most horrific flus that we've experienced in the past hundred years
have come as a direct result of this type of farming.
Yes,
that's right.
Uh,
the,
um,
the concentration,
the,
the total unnatural concentration and,
and buildup of toxicity in these places is incredible.
And so what happens is that the industry uses concoctions,
you know,
um,
from,
from something as benign as chlorine all the way to,
you know,
a stiffer stuff to try to sanitize clean,
wash down,
all that stuff.
But all that does is,
um,
is open the door for the survivors.
And every and every time a new concoction is developed,
there are survivors and the survivors become more and more virulent.
So that,
for example,
when the industry says all look,
eat coal lie,
it's been around forever,
you know,
get over it.
A ECOLAB is part of a cow's digestion.
Well that's true,
but not the virulent strains that we're developing by feeding unnatural feeds
and the drugs and so were,
those would normally be fairly benign in are highly acidic digestive system.
They become more virulent and they survive in us instead of us killing them.
And that's this evolution of things.
I mean,
you know,
uh,
take,
um,
you know,
Arkansas now where the,
where the farmers are now budgeting $70 per acre to hand machete super weeds
that have morphed as a result of glyphosate roundup because of genetically
modified organism,
a corn and soybeans being planted.
It,
it's created these survivor super weeds because everything,
whenever we try to sterilize or sanitize,
there are survivors and those survivors become tougher and tougher and tougher.
We are a bunch of dummies,
aren't we?
I mean really are as a human race.
We're just a bunch of silly dummies.
There's a,
there's a,
an issue that,
uh,
is a big one with antibiotic soaps.
A lot of people think it's real smart to wash with antibiotic soaps,
but what they don't realize is the antibiotic soaps kill all the good flora on
your screen as well.
And it seems like that's really similar to what's going on here.
Absolutely.
Your talk of the live betting would,
that is his nature zone way of dealing with the passages instead of pumping some
chemicals into them.
That's right.
And there's nothing unnatural about it.
In other words,
you don't get.
You don't get virulent survivors.
They're all on an equal,
you know,
a creation playing field,
if you will.
And,
and,
and all.
And our responsibility then is simply to create a habitat
that allows this,
this,
um,
battlefield to play out in its natural setting.
Natural setting is the key because there is a sort of a give and take,
a place,
a jigsaw puzzle piece place for all the various elements of a farm,
of an ecosystem.
And that's what you're addressing when you're.
That's when I found so incredibly fascinating about the,
the idea of continuing to move these animals and you have these very low voltage
electric fences that are just enough.
So they go up,
I don't want to go near there.
No one's getting hurt,
but they're like,
no,
it's,
it's called a psychological barrier to essentially car battery you use,
right?
So it's portable.
Well,
it's an energy.
It's a car battery,
power car,
battery
and energizer.
Uh,
it has high voltage but no amperage.
So,
you know,
you get a lot of pain,
but there's no danger because you're running like,
you know,
uh,
goodness,
you know,
uh,
a 20th of an amp.
Okay.
I mean there's,
there's no energy,
but there's a.
but,
but there's a lot of pressure.
Uh,
and so,
um,
so,
you know,
these systems,
again,
these are computer microchip systems.
So,
you know,
I think,
I think as we've talked about,
how did the factory farm develop?
I think perhaps,
you know,
rather than a continuum,
you can go wherever you want to with the questions.
But I would like to to point out to folks that as bad as that is and depressing
and yeah,
we're a bunch of dummies and all that.
My goodness,
we have now innovated the most amazing infrastructure to be able for the first
time in human history to caress our Earth Nest,
our lover,
if you will,
more strategically and purposely purposefully than we have ever been able to do
it before.
And the tech and the infrastructure is amazing.
One is electric fencing.
I mean you can now in,
in a wheelbarrow full of material,
you can now place hundreds of thousands of animals in a certain spot for a day
and,
and manage carefully their intersection with a given piece of nature that's,
that's unprecedented.
We've never been able to do that before.
I'm week and we can protect them.
We can make them comfortable not with stationary barns and you know,
big post and beam,
you know,
you have to cut down the whole forest to do this.
But now with bandsaw band saw a technology instead of,
you know,
the big old circular saws that removed a quarter of an inch per cut.
I'm now with a little Honda engine that,
that saps that's just sips fuel and uh,
and a one 10th of an inch thick,
a bandsaw.
We can now mill tinker toy,
like lab structure material to build very lightweight,
portable barnes,
portable shelters.
So we,
we use those on our farm.
We have all these portable infrastructures for Turkeys,
chickens,
cows,
pigs,
um,
so that we can move a shade tree or a barn protective shelter with the animals,
with a four wheeler,
uh,
you know,
a couple of guys pushing it along.
Okay.
This portable infrastructure then,
um,
allows us to keep the animals controlled and comfortable.
And with black pipe black pipe,
we can les miles with black power black plastic pipe.
Okay.
We can now develop a pond or a spring and put that water in a nice,
clean,
you know,
delivery system,
like the plumbing in your house and deliver it miles.
So the animals aren't,
you know,
drinking out of their toilet.
They're not,
you know,
pooping and in drinking out of it and all that,
like you see that they're actually eating.
I drink out of the cal troughs.
I mean,
that water's clean enough for me to drink.
You drink out of that.
Absolutely owe it.
It builds up your immune system.
Oh,
system does it.
Yeah.
You ever get sick?
You know,
knock on wood.
I haven't been sick for years.
I don't remember the last time I was sick with a cold.
Really?
Yeah.
Will it really?
I mean,
I'll take a lot of vitamin C every day.
Um,
you know,
ascorbic acid.
I'd take my,
uh,
you know,
Dopa tropic for keep me from going crazy with still patrol.
It's a,
it's an urban mix.
It,
you know,
it,
it's related to dopamine and stuff,
but it,
it,
it's a,
it's a calmer.
It's a CA.
I travel so much now that in such an unnatural environment,
you know,
I,
I was starting a couple years ago,
I was starting into a kind of a fight or flight subconscious fight or flight
thing where I would get,
I couldn't breathe,
you know,
on our airplane and stuff because it was,
and,
and you know,
I'd get all congested and all this and uh,
I went to a,
went to a quack and alternative medical practitioner that,
that uses the kind of machines they use in Europe.
You know,
when you go to the emergency room in Europe and you grab two probes and a little
needle,
you know,
tells you everything that's wrong with you,
it costs like pennies,
you know,
I mean,
that's how they can get along with government healthcare because they actually
are smart about it.
You know,
when these probes you hold on with your hands and they tell you what's wrong
with you.
Intelligent.
Yeah.
No,
it's pretty cool.
Anyway,
I mean it's not endorsed by any medical.
Oh,
absolutely.
Listen,
called.
I thought it was funny too.
I went from my first visit,
I sat down,
she said somewhere in your background you had a.
You had a bladder issue,
didn't you?
I didn't,
I hadn't said a word.
I mean,
I'm 57 right when I was.
How old was I?
Eight.
I had a malfunctioning kidney valve
malfunction.
Kidney Valve almost died.
I mean this was long time ago,
right?
It went in with surgery and repaired that valve board.
It was doing,
it was letting my urine backup for my bladder backup into the kid.
It's a one way check valve.
Okay.
So your bladder is under pressure,
right?
And,
and,
and that you're in is supposed to only go one direction.
All right.
Into the bladder.
Well,
I had one malfunctioning valve that was letting as the bladder filled up with
pressure.
It was the balloon was pushing the urine back up into the kidney.
All right.
So they went in and repaired it anyway,
in,
in 10 minutes,
her machine picked up that which was,
you know,
50 year,
a 50 year old,
whatever,
you know,
bodily injury,
problem.
Um,
and,
and boy,
you know,
I sat up and saluted at that point,
this is what's the machine called?
I don't know what the machine's called.
If,
uh,
if I,
if I knew more about it than somebody would come after me and put me in jail.
PROAC watches.
Is that the same machine right here?
It says that that's one of the machines.
There's different kinds of models of it,
I'm guessing.
Yeah.
Were there to quack watch though?
This is a website that saying it's a quack.
Well,
I don't know if it's that machine or not.
I don't want to tell you who she is because she probably get put in jail if you
knew who she was.
But really she gets on the Ama.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
the Ama goes after people.
My goodness,
they go after raw milk producers and backyard chicken
can growers.
And that's,
that is a true story.
That's a true fact.
The Orthodoxy Orthodoxy.
That's really crazy today.
And of course you know,
we're heretics and the inquisition is very real.
Yeah.
Fooling patients with computerized magic eight balls on if that's the same
thing.
I,
I have
no idea.
I,
I purposely try to not know all about it.
So that means a real craziness.
If you've ever seen the uh,
there was a story recently where they,
they,
they arrested people like with a swat team for selling raw milk.
I mean they,
they,
they broke down doors and they had guns and they were wearing bulletproof vests
and they're just,
they're just a farm milk.
And then somehow or another,
because we've made milk so toxic because of these environments that you're
describing that you would,
you drink raw milk on a
farm,
like your farm where the cows are healthy.
I mean you could drink that raw milk and it's actually easily digested.
Your body digests it far more easy.
And a lot of people that are even lactose intolerant don't have a problem with
the raw milk.
Right.
And,
and the,
you know,
the milk from an industrial farm is toxic.
It does have a lot of problems.
A lot of people don't realize that the Mayo Clinic was built.
I mean,
it started back during the early time of the century when,
um,
when cows were eating brewery brewery,
waste distiller's grains because they were,
you know,
without refrigeration,
you put the,
they put the breweries and the cows together and in these urban sectors and you
know,
they didn't understand bacteria and hygiene and sanitation,
all that stuff.
So the cows got a brucellosis and all these things,
pass it onto people.
And Mayo clinic started putting cows back on pasture and feeding raw milk to
their patients during the time when people were getting sick from urban
industrial swill fed cow milk.
And that's how Mayo Clinic actually started.
So that's a um,
yeah,
I mean,
raw milk is a,
is a wonderful,
uh,
material,
but the cow has to be treated like a cow,
you know,
you have to respect her countless as a cow.
That's how I picked their countless.
That's how,
that's how you get.
You don't,
you don't get to all the milkiness of milk if you don't respect the counters of
the cow.
Right?
And so what's happened is that the industry is so filthy and pathogen and toxic
that,
um,
you know,
and people fear food because they're,
the average person is fearful of food.
I mean the average person is far more informed about the latest dysfunction and
the carnation household than they are,
you know,
uh,
what's going to become flesh with their flesh and bone of their bones at 6:00.
I liked how you pronounced it card.
It shows you really don't
know.
I don't.
So whatever they are,
whoever they are exactly.
Still asking though,
but
it's all about.
So you need to put a button on TV.
People Watch.
So the point is though,
that people are so paranoid of food and ignorant about food,
that they fear food today.
People,
I mean we have customers call us up if I thought chicken in a sink.
Well it gets Salmonella.
You know,
I mean there's a.
If there's a profound ignorance in our culture regarding food because we're
disconnected from it.
And so afraid people asked for security from the government.
Well the government says,
well,
let's see what should be our protocols.
They go to the industry for the answers and concoct an orthodoxy that actually
shuts out the antidote for the very problems they're trying to solve.
The idea that the government would have any solutions whatsoever to that it's
pretty ridiculous in the first place because who would be the person that would
be an expert on this?
Would it be the industry that,
that creates?
A lot of these problems we need is a guy like you working for the government.
Oh,
I wouldn't work if I got chosen to work for the government.
Whatever agency I was in charge of,
uh,
I'd shut it down before Sundance.
What would you do if,
let's say,
let's say there's some catastrophic failure of our government and they just
decided to quit and everybody just decided to go under and we need to figure out
how to regulate farms.
Um,
what,
what would,
what could be done?
What can be done at this point?
I mean,
you,
you suggesting that the factory farms there,
there,
there's no retrofit.
They shouldn't be destroyed and be better off building miniature golf courses
over.
Um,
how would we be able to distribute food to a nation of hungry people?
Is it possible to use your methods,
the methods you use,
and how big is your farm in Virginia?
Well,
we own 550 acres and we leased another nine farms.
So we're,
we're running 2000 acres.
Uh,
and,
and we're producing,
we're producing a lot of food.
In fact,
you know,
we,
we surpassed the county average in production on passenger by about threefold.
A threefold amount,
which is pretty significant.
So factory farms given the same amount of space,
produce less.
Yeah.
In fact,
I mean,
the thing that's important to realize when you look at a factory farm,
when the industry shows this picture of this big chicken house or this big,
big factory or hog or,
or,
you know,
calfee lot,
um,
or,
uh,
or uh,
a,
know a square mile of strawberries in California.
Um,
what you have to understand is those systems are not standalone islands.
When they say,
look at the efficiency of the small footprint,
what they're not showing you are the square miles,
balls of,
of subsidized grain or petroleum inputs.
The land area that all that takes to sustain that little footprint and then the
land that it takes to assimilate all of the waste stream from that.
So our system doesn't take one more,
one more square yard of production than,
than the factory system.
The fact that we're doing,
um,
you know,
stackable,
synergistic,
symbiotic,
multi speciated enterprises,
it's more productive.
But,
um,
but when you look at what we're producing,
even though at first glance,
the uneducated might say,
well,
it takes a lot more land to produce them this way.
Actually,
you're seeing all the land.
Just like when people say,
well,
it takes more people farming to do it your way.
Yeah.
But you know what,
we don't have fixing pollution areas.
We don't have people burying people with C diff and,
and,
and Murcia,
uh,
we don't know.
We're not making people sick from Salmonella and e coli are you with.
I mean,
so,
so in toto,
all we're doing is taking all the people that are currently trying to,
uh,
trying to triage the collateral damage of cheap food.
We're taking all those people and growing the food
and all those jobs are coming back to the farm instead of being in,
you know,
and whatever a costly remedial programs they are.
So you are essentially a standalone system,
whereas when you're seeing a factory farm,
there's a lot.
Absolutely not seeing that's required to make that thing run.
That's exactly right.
Now we do buy grain for are omnivores,
but we buy local,
GMO free grain,
no genetically modified organisms.
And uh,
and yes,
um,
you know,
the whole idea is to um,
create a carbon centricity so that we're not you.
We're not shipping this stuff all over the place and when people say all but a
locality can't produce it.
Cornell did a fascinating study several years ago of New York.
They took every metropolitan city,
you know,
Ithaca,
Syracuse,
Buffalo,
Albany,
New York City,
and he took all the cities of New York and said,
could we produce the calories for these urban sectors?
You know,
how much land would it take?
And what they found was that every urban sector could produce all of its
calories within 30 miles.
So even in New York,
it could be standalone,
self-sufficient,
except for New York City,
which if they went into New Jersey it became self sufficient as well because New
York's right on the edge of the,
you know,
right on the edge of the state.
And so I'm so a fundamentally integrated system rather than a segregated system
becomes far more efficient in,
in the scheme of things,
it comes far more efficient than a segregated system with all this,
you know,
all this long distance transportation because the ships are passing in the
night.
That's what's happening.
You know,
Iowa produces all this food.
I will only eat only five percent of the food that's eaten in Iowa is grown in
Iowa
and Iowa is the most fertile piece of land in the,
in the planet.
Why?
Because they're there.
They're not producing food.
There's nothing to eat there.
You know,
if you want to eat,
you know,
berries and apples and things.
There has to be imported from somewhere else because the whole states and corn
and soybeans,
this gmo genetically modified things.
A real hot topic.
It is genetically modified.
Seems to me to be along the same lines of his factory farming idea is that
you're,
you,
instead of looking at it in a comprehensive approach,
what you're doing is saying,
well,
we got a problem.
Let's attack that problem with chemicals.
Yes.
Well,
it's,
it's fundamentally bridging.
It's fundamentally,
I'm overrunning a lot of natural barriers that are there in place to protect,
to protect happening what is happening,
which is a,
um,
a mishmash of genetic material.
So you have a,
you know,
a salmon that's partly a pepper plant,
partly,
uh,
you know,
a tropical urban park pig.
Okay.
And,
um,
and,
and you talk about,
you mentioned allergies a little bit in the past,
the,
when we were kids,
I didn't know anybody with a food allergy.
We didn't even know the phrase,
I never even heard the phrase,
okay.
And now it's ubiquitous.
What's happening is that we're getting all of this,
um,
this Frankenfood,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's our,
our internal bacteria.
You know,
we've got 3 trillion beings and our insides and they're not capable of mutating.
And I'm assimilating material as fast as our human brains can adulterate the
food system.
And so what happens is we're sending down there a bunch of foreign material.
What's this?
You know,
I can just see him talking to,
let's have a board meeting here and see what that,
you know,
gmo corn is.
And so what happens is,
you know,
they can't assimilate it.
And so the other thing about gmos is that it is hard to contain,
you know,
by nature it's promiscuous.
So what you have here is a new life form.
I mean,
the only thing that,
that people have been able to do before now is a mule.
I'm,
it's a donkey on a horse.
Makes a mule.
But a mule is sterile.
It's almost like God says,
all right,
you can do that,
you know,
donkey on horse.
But that's it.
You know,
you're not going to go anymore than that.
This is not Mendel's peas.
Mendel was peas on peace.
He wasn't pees on tomatoes,
on pigs,
on monkeys,
you know,
it was,
it was within specie.
And so this is a,
um,
a,
you know,
this is an assault on the sexual plumbing that nature has to maintain genetic
purity and it seems like the DDT issue hasn't been factored in as far as the
longterm,
if that price.
That's right.
Yeah.
The feeding trials,
all the feeding trials have only been like,
you know,
60 days,
60 days is nothing.
Not only that,
but if you know the,
probably the world expert on this as Jeffrey Smith who wrote seeds of deception
and is the,
the,
the premier world GMO expert.
He points out that when,
you know,
when Monsanto was doing feeding trials for FDA on,
for example,
potatoes,
a GMO,
potatoes they chose for the feeding trial,
geriatric rats.
Well,
geriatric rats are already completely form.
You know,
you're not going to see any big changes in those in Scotland.
When the,
uh,
scientists,
they're duplicated those studies with juvenile rats,
same feeding trial,
same potatoes,
same everything,
all sorts of problems develop cognitive ability,
brain fog.
They couldn't go through a maze,
a organ development,
kidney malfunction,
a fertility problems.
I mean,
you name it.
I had all these problems.
So,
you know,
one of the,
one of the problems with science is that it's very subjective.
You can set up an experiment within your paradigm.
You know,
Teddy Roosevelt used to say,
it's really hard to see,
it's really hard to get a guy to see something when his paycheck believes a
depends on seeing something else as a good way of putting it.
And I think that's exactly what's happened here,
that you can set up experiments and,
and constrict the parameters,
whether it's length of time,
type of subject,
you know,
you name it,
but you can set up the parameters of the experiment
to skew the results,
to not get a comprehensive eclectic view like the geriatric read,
like the geriatric rats.
And that seems like dirty pool.
That's,
that's a bad thing that they do.
Yeah.
They do.
In doing this just for profit.
Absolutely.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of money on the line,
a lot of money on the line.
I,
um,
and
so,
you know,
so where are we going to go from here?
How do we go from here?
And so,
you know,
when you ask,
well,
you know what,
what could you do?
All right,
we know this system is bad,
how do we,
how do we really move over here?
And
there are several answers.
I mean,
one is,
you know,
go underground,
just start buying the good stuff.
I'm guerrilla type marketing,
but I think the main one is the,
what we need is a food emancipation proclamation.
We need a food emancipation proclamation to free the food system from the
enslavement of bureaucratic orthodoxy
so that consenting adults,
and I'm choosing my words very carefully here so that consenting adults could
make a voluntary choice of food choice,
the type that they want from the source that they want.
And if we allowed however many in our society,
five percent,
10 percent,
20 percent,
who ever didn't,
can whoever wanted to opt out of government sanctioned orthodoxy and say,
hmm,
is there something better out here?
Can I choose something different?
If anybody who wanted to opt out of the of the current industrial government
orthodoxy could do so,
no voluntary consenting adults here.
You know,
we're talking about the right of private contract.
If I want to,
if I want to come to your farm voluntarily,
no extortion here,
okay?
Voluntarily look around,
smell around,
ask around and I want what you're producing.
I should be able to get it.
When the government gets between my lips and my throat,
I call that an invasion of privacy and yes,
I do also believe that we should legalize all drugs,
all of them,
because the government that can tell you you can't smoke dope can also tell you
can't drink raw milk or,
or,
or refuse to vaccinate your children or you know,
go down the line.
The fact is that the orthodoxy is so convoluted now that it's perfectly safe and
fine to feed your kids Coca Cola,
mountain dew count Chocula,
cheerio's and pop tarts,
but not homemade charcuterie.
Pickles,
raw milk and backyard butcher chickens.
Not Crazy.
It's absolutely crazy.
And if we would free up,
I mean,
I travel a lot.
I talked to thousands and thousands of farmers.
I just talked to 200 farmers up in San Jose this weekend.
You know,
and what's the limiting factor?
Why is local food cheap?
Why is our kind of food,
I mean cheap,
more expensive than it has to be.
Why are we perceived as elitist?
Why isn't it more available?
Why is it so hard to find integrity food?
This is the issue.
And if we would free up those of us in the system that are ready to access our
neighbors with quiche and noodles and charcuterie and you know,
a name,
your name it to free us up,
it would,
it would completely invert the entire food system in a year.
The entire food system as you speak of like when you're talking about the
genetically modified organisms and you're talking about these companies that
provide them like Monsanto.
There's a backlash against that now because of the information that's been
released about the detrimental effects of them.
And you're seeing like in Brazil,
they won lawsuits,
a farmers one massive lawsuits against Monsanto and these,
um,
various GMO products that they've created.
Say what you're talking about Iowa and the fertility of the land in Iowa.
What,
what could,
what could possibly happen?
How could those all these farms that are set up to just specifically grow grains
and a lot of them grains that are specifically grown just to feed livestock or
make alcohol,
that,
is that what it is to like?
Well,
yeah,
of course,
you know,
all the alcohol,
corn,
alcohol,
that's what I'm,
most of the farms,
a lot of it already.
But go ahead with the massive amounts of Ronnie are invested in these systems.
What could they do?
I mean,
what could be done to change all that?
Could those farms be sort of turned around and brought to a more of a
comprehensive approach to farming?
Like you're prescribing what the deliveries
stables do when the automobile came?
That's what we're talking about here.
Think about that transition.
Um,
uh,
think about the horse drawn Hackney's when the electric streetcar came.
I mean,
you're talking that,
that's the level of change here.
You're talking about massive societal change.
There'll be some losers,
but you know what?
Those guys have been making fun of me and calling me a bio terrorist and a
lunatic and a,
you know,
a
terrorist because our chickens can commune with redwing blackbirds and Indigo
buntings out in the field,
and then those wild birds take our diseases to the science based environmentally
controlled factory chicken houses and threatened the planet's food supply all
because we were so archaic and Neanderthal that we had our chickens running
around in the pasture.
Has that really been argued?
Absolutely.
You've really had that.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
You,
barbarian,
you let your chickens run loose?
Absolutely.
In fact,
I had two federal veterinarians when the last time we had an avian flu outbreak
in,
uh,
in Virginia back about 12 years ago.
Um,
and they,
by the way,
they exterminated landfilled 1000 tractor trailer loads of port,
of,
of a poultry,
1000 tractor trailer loads of poultry within just about a five county area of
me.
Wow.
Alright.
Did they then in turn feed that poultry back to other chickens
after they killed him?
No.
No,
that was not because that was avian flu.
So they,
they actually landfilled or incinerated,
wow.
Burned it up.
But see,
under our system you don't have any of that stuff.
So I mean,
a thousand tractor trailer loads is a lot of food.
All right.
Anyway,
I had two vets there that were part of the extermination of federal tax force.
Both of them said that,
um,
that we are considered,
I mean,
they,
they came to visit because they'd read about us,
oh we're,
we're here,
you know,
they came from Oklahoma,
whatever.
We'll go see this place.
And both of them said that we are considered a typhoid Mary in the,
in the community B,
b,
because,
you know,
we don't,
we don't vaccinate,
we don't medicate and we don't,
you know,
uh,
we don't do all the orthodoxy that the industry says you're supposed to do.
I mean,
that's the orthodoxy.
See that's the.
And if you don't,
if you don't adhere to that,
and of course that then that orthodoxy drives insurance.
How does the farmer sells product?
How does he get product liability insurance?
The insurance company says,
well,
we won't underwrite you unless you use best agricultural practices.
Will the insurance company doesn't know anything about agriculture,
where are they going to find out about what's best agricultural practices that
Dang,
they ring up the land grant university,
which is the lackey of the industry,
and they say,
well,
you need this protocol of vaccinations,
this protocol of medications,
this protocol of chlorine,
this protocol,
and if the farm doesn't do that,
it's high risk.
It's high risk form.
You better not do it.
And so right now a lot of farmers like us are unable to get insurance because
the underwriters won't insure risky farming,
which
is which,
which goes against the orthodoxy of the system because the insurance executives
played golf with the,
you know,
the,
uh,
the industrial ag executives play golf with the bureaucracy,
the bureaucracy,
executives.
It's all a big fraternity.
It's not a conspiracy.
It's a fraternity of ideas and they've all drunk the Koolaid.
Dad is madness and it's incredibly frustrating because you're so transparent
about your process and the benefits of your process when you're sitting out
there.
In one of the videos that I watched you sitting out there with these pigs,
these pigs are just hanging out there.
They come up to you like the pig got under your arm and your leg,
put your arm on him.
He's like,
Hey,
what's up?
Yeah.
You know when the.
They just rooting around and,
and anybody that wouldn't see the benefits of that,
you have to be either.
You have to have a financial vested interest in not seeing it.
Oh,
you have to be insane.
Yeah.
You have to be in say a.
The best compliment I ever got was a young chef.
Young chef came eight,
wanted to see the farm.
You starting to buy our stuff and really liked it.
He wanted to come and see the pics.
I took him up to the pigs.
He says,
you know,
I,
it was a young guy.
He said,
I have never.
I've never seen a live pig.
You know,
he,
he cuts them up and cook them all the time,
but he never been physically present with a live pig and he just got really
quiet.
I just let him,
you know,
enjoy it for a little while and the pigs were knowing on his shoe strings and
just there and he finally said,
you know,
I don't know anything about raising pigs,
but I think if I was a pig,
this is the way I'd want to live
into.
It resonates in our soul.
I mean,
if you have,
if you have a conscience at all,
it resonates in your conscience.
Yeah.
Here's your pigs up here on the screen.
I mean,
these pigs are just chilling.
Yeah,
they're having a great time.
They're not stuck in some disgusting Penn,
whether they're lumped in.
I mean,
there was a story recently of
a farmer who they believe fell.
They believe he may have had a heart attack,
is that older gentleman fell into a pick up a pen and was killed by the pigs,
but he mean that's in everybody's like,
all pigs are vicious.
It's the conditions that are vicious.
These pigs aren't going to kill anybody.
These pigs come right up to the in nozzle with you.
Man.
I've seen it.
They,
they will kill you if you quit moving.
They're omnivores.
You know,
yeah.
If you,
if you're dead,
tell kindergarteners that want to go in and pet them.
I said,
absolutely.
You're welcome to go in and pet them.
Just keep wiggling.
That's hilarious.
Your toes first and your fingers that in an hour there'll be to your spleen,
you know,
so uh,
wow.
Keep moving.
They are omnivores and they are survivors.
They are,
they're very cool.
That's one of the interesting things about pigs is this huge problem with feral,
what we call feral hogs because they're not a native species to North America
and they don't really have any natural predators other than,
you know,
coyotes which have sort of taken them on and mountain lions and all the other
animals that we have in North America.
But the number one invasive species problem we have as far as like big animals,
his pigs.
There again,
there again,
the problem,
it's a political problem.
It's not a,
it's not an ecological problem.
You know,
in Europe they have feral pigs too,
but it's not a problem.
You know why?
Because you can go out and shoot a pig and sell it to a restaurant,
you can sell it to a neighbor.
They allow,
you know,
wild shot animals,
deer and pigs to go into commerce.
Sorry about that though,
is from a sportsman's point of view that you're going to have people out there
sniping and poaching deer and all the really precious wild animals and selling
them to restaurants and there won't be any there for hunter.
The thing is nature has a way of balancing it out and when there's an
overpopulation,
they're easy to get and then once they.
Once they get harder to get.
Yeah.
Then people,
then people get discouraged from hunting because they're too hard to get.
I would be more in support of that for pigs.
Then the other animals simply because pigs breed all year round,
they'll get off several litters a year of many,
but whereas a deer will have one fond,
you know,
and they'll have a phone or two and they'll have them once a year.
Well maybe you could control it with licenses.
Just give people,
you know,
you can.
You can harvest so many a deer,
so many a year,
whatever.
I mean,
there's a lot of ways to skin the cat.
The bottom line I'm getting too though,
is that when you,
when you prohibit a food source from entering commerce,
you,
you automatically have the government manipulating a,
a,
a supply and demand situation.
That's the reality.
And so,
uh,
so you know,
the,
the people that are,
that are concerned about,
and you go down some areas,
I'm,
yeah,
the wild pig problem is a real,
it's a real land abuse problem where they're having him in suburban San Jose,
San Jose as people are having their lawns chewed up.
There was a big news story about it the other day where they showed these pigs
running across people's lawns and this normal suburban street,
they're chewing up their lawn.
They're resourceful and they're smart,
but,
you know,
pitching the smartest,
supposedly one of the smartest animals there is.
And,
and they are,
they're,
they're really,
uh,
they're really smart.
So,
so if we would,
if we would allow people to actually practice,
I'm consenting adult voluntary commerce on some of these things.
It would,
it would then incentivize innovation,
entrepreneurship and the antidote to all of the depressing things we've talked
about [inaudible] and,
and um,
and our side then would rise and the other side would have to adapt.
They'd either have to down,
I mean,
there,
there's talk,
for example,
right now among the poultry industry of trying to go antibiotic free in 10 years
and uh,
in order to do it,
they're going to have to greatly drop the bird size in their houses.
And I know that there's a lot of research going into building these living
compost bedding situations in these houses.
Even in the poultry industry.
Yes.
In,
in the poultry industry.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
Denmark,
Denmark made the change.
They outlawed,
I'm a factory pork houses years ago.
They'd been fine.
They've gone too deep bedded,
you know,
houses completely different situation and um,
and it makes it a completely different living environment.
So,
you know,
you can,
um,
you can make those changes.
They're not,
they're not insurmountable.
And those changes though still are not where you're at.
You're in,
you've got these animals moving around and his giant farm and you move your
electric fences from place to place.
What?
What's the,
the method like how do you get the animals to move?
Like when you,
like you have them in one area for like a day day.
Yeah.
How big is the area that you.
Lemon.
Let's take cows.
I mean,
we've gone as,
as tight as a 400 head on two acres for a day.
I mean that's pretty tight at and an acre is a football field just for people
trying to visualize what's an acre.
It's roughly a football field.
So,
you know,
imagine 400 cows on two acres.
That's pretty dense.
All.
Yeah.
Um,
but the beauty is that when you move them all the time like this,
they get very docile.
I mean,
you know,
their route,
their routine and you incentivize it because every day at 4:00 when you go out
and call them,
they're going to a new salad bar everyday at 4:00,
a certain call meant there's a bowl of ice cream for you.
You know,
you'd get pretty used to that call as well.
Is that what you do?
You call them?
We call them.
We don't hurt them,
we call it.
What do you call?
Do you have a noisy make?
And so they hear that and they know it's a little dinner Bell Dinner Bell.
Yeah.
And they just,
they just fall right on.
Wow.
So,
uh,
then you set up this new,
you put the stakes down,
set up this new area,
the fences,
totally portable.
So you're essentially,
I mean,
envision a field like a ladder and the permanent fit,
the,
the edges of the field are the,
are the,
um,
the stringers of the ladder and the portable fences are the rungs.
So the permanent are there all the time and we simply move the rungs,
you know,
contract or expand the rungs based on how much grasser is,
how many there are in the herd,
get that sort of thing.
So it's,
it's a very artistic,
you know,
there's a science,
but there's also an art to it as we,
as we essentially give them one plateful of day.
And you alternate animals in these areas.
Yeah,
so the cows go through first,
then the egg mobiles come in after them,
so after the cows are there and then you push the chicken house in there.
He fence that in as well.
That's not fit.
Those chickens can run anywhere they want to.
They just,
they just hang around the egg mobile because that's where feed and water and
nest boxes.
So you don't have to fence them and don't have to fence them.
They,
they go out,
you know,
up to 200 yards and scavenge and scratch out cow patties and when it starts
getting dark they come back and it will start coming back in.
So we have it in our yard.
We,
we have,
we leave the door open.
Exactly.
And then at the end,
at night we shut the door.
They know that.
I mean,
you know,
chickens or your chicken scared,
right?
I mean we use the word slang and so they're in,
their instinct is to get somewhere secure for the night.
They don't want to just sit out on the ground night.
So there.
So the,
your,
your coop or the egg immobile.
That's a secure place.
And they naturally are drawn to that,
uh,
as,
as the dark starts to go down.
So for them,
you don't have to worry about that.
You just move this giant structure that you've created,
which is very innovative.
Is this your design?
The structure?
Yeah.
See if you can pull up the egg immobile because it's pretty interesting to see
if he could find the video of it.
It was in one of those,
uh,
w polyface,
that's what you call it.
Polyface farm is one of those videos your design,
you just figured out how to stack them in there and this way.
Well,
essentially it's essentially,
it's a,
it's a chicken house on wheels is what it is.
And uh,
so you know,
where you,
where you would normally make a chicken house for example.
Yeah.
There you go.
Where you normally make a chicken house,
a stationary.
This is simply modeled on wheels,
on an axle,
all like a trailer,
and you just hooked up to it with a tractor and the chickens are all inside and
you can move it up the public road or to the far side of the field or whatever.
And there's the guard dog,
the guard dogs with them as well,
and the guard dog keeps coyotes,
coyotes and hawks and things that like drumsticks for dinner.
He keeps those away.
We lost the chicken.
We don't know what happened.
I'm pretty sure it was a Hark.
Something just scoop one up.
Just vish.
Just vanished.
No.
Yeah,
there's no nothing.
Oh yeah,
they,
uh,
they do.
That's why you got a lot of chickens,
man.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's,
that's,
that's a lot of chickens.
That's a thousand chickens.
Now.
Those egg ligand laying chickens are those.
Those are egg layers and you have different chickens that are egg laying
chickens in different chickens that are meat chicken.
That's right.
Dairy and beef.
A dairy,
dairy,
cows,
a grow.
Make a lot of milk.
Beef cows grow bulkier.
Same Way with a chickens.
Layers.
Layers have a.
they're genetically selected.
Those breeds,
um,
they lay eggs and they have a physique more like,
Koby Bryant and the meat chickens have,
have a seat,
have a physique.
I'm more like,
got Emmitt Smith.
Okay,
great.
If you're going to eat it,
you want to Emmett Smith,
if you want to lay an egg,
you want to coby Brian.
Gotcha.
Coby Brian
called coby Brian Agler.
Um,
so it's,
so,
it's essentially just the breed of chicken self.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
I mean all these,
I mean a hogs,
sheep,
sheep are known for their,
especially for their wool,
you know,
like the,
like the Merinos,
you know,
they're known for their wool.
Others are known more for their meat,
a pigs.
Some pigs are known for their fat.
They were called Lard hogs,
uh,
back in the day we ate lard,
you know,
and,
and so they would get real fat,
uh,
other picture known for the length of their loin,
others for their maternal instincts,
you know,
big,
big litters.
So yeah,
all of these breeds have different characteristics.
Do you only have hands or do you have roosters as well?
We have roosters as well.
The eggs are not all,
we don't have enough roosters to fertilize all of them,
but we do have enough roosters so that,
you know,
we get kids can watch them cro and we can,
um,
I've had a lot of people say that,
uh,
that are um,
transcendentalists or you know,
that,
um,
if,
if that,
if we actually come back as a different being,
they really want to come back as a rooster at polyphase.
Why?
Because they got about 200 hens per rooster.
It seems like you get out run.
It would just start running.
They would tell you what to do.
Yeah.
They can get hit and pecked.
D.
Yeah.
Hand.
That's the other term.
Chickens being scared and Henpeck.
Those are both real and henpecks do pac man.
Oh yeah.
They do wild pigs in San Jose
and they.
Oh Wow,
look at that.
Yeah,
he's getting,
he's getting food,
right?
I mean they have a real problem now.
It's just starting to make its way up there.
A lot of people don't associate California with wild pigs.
Um,
what I was getting at was,
do you breed your own chickens?
Do you,
do.
We have just started,
we've just started.
We haven't in the past.
We've always gotten it from a hatchery.
But what we've seen,
you'd find this fascinating.
I'm sure what we've seen is in my lifetime,
and I'm not that old,
but I have watched the genetic viability of lot of animals,
of domestic livestock a drop because of the props that we,
the crutches that we use antibiotics,
a hot feed candy bar.
I called candy bar diets
and unnatural feeding regimens.
And so,
um,
we have really seen the,
the strength that the,
just,
the,
the viability of these farm animals plummet.
So our son Daniel,
uh,
when he was eight,
started with rabbits and these are meat rabbits,
not pet rabbits,
but their meat rabbits.
Some friends had a couple of those and a buck and they,
uh,
they,
they couldn't take them to a new apartment where they were moving.
So they said,
you know,
would you like these rabbits?
Well,
he was Kinda,
he was eight,
you know,
eight years old is about the time to start an entrepreneur business,
you know.
And so he said,
uh,
um,
as I started with chickens when I was 10,
so I was two years late,
but,
uh,
he started rapping when he was eight and so he said,
yeah,
I'll take,
I wanted to raise some race,
some rabbits.
So he did that and if you read any like,
you know,
rabbit rearing book,
it'll say never give them grass,
you know,
don't give them that because they'll get diarrhea and die.
And of course that's exactly what we found.
But,
but what he did,
he did,
he did what's called line breeding,
which is kind of a wild breeding.
And it took him five years to work through a lot of mortality and calling.
But in five years the rabbit started really getting strong,
vibrant,
big litters.
Healthy.
Now 24 years later,
they're almost bulletproof.
And,
and what we've seen in the,
in the,
uh,
the genetic selection process over that time of not using any crutches and just
letting it be kind of a,
a,
you know,
a Darwinian selection process has made us now want to want to do that,
duplicate that with our other animals.
And so we've,
we started last year with our chickens taking our oldest,
what we call survivor genetics,
the oldest hands that are still laying,
mating them to the roosters.
And what we want to do is just keep taking the oldest hens,
meeting them back to the,
meeting them to the roosters.
So we eventually create a survivor genetic.
In other words,
that's the chicken that new to hide.
When the Hawk came,
that's the chicken that knew to get under shelter when the rain came,
that's the chicken that,
that didn't get flu,
that didn't get bugged,
that didn't have a prolapse.
The first eggs she did,
I mean,
I call it survivor genetics.
We're doing that now with our cows.
We're selecting our own bulls and breeding from our own bulls.
And we're very excited about what this,
this kind of wild line breeding pipe type of thing can do if you knock out all
the crutches.
Um,
the problem is that it puts you crossways of the animal welfare crowd because
they can't,
they can't abide the idea that if I have a sick animal,
I'm just going to let it die.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
You know,
they've been Bambi and thumper right into death to where every,
every,
um,
you know,
every dog and cat has to have a monogram ll bean,
cushing in an air condition,
any room.
And that's,
that's the only way to care for animals.
And the problem is that we don't,
we're not going to get genetic strength if we don't let nature call out the weak
links.
That's the problem,
you know?
And so,
um,
so we wouldn't have the vibrant rabbits that Daniel has if we had started at the
beginning,
oh,
let's properties up with antibiotics.
So the weak ones can survive if everybody walks into the room wearing crutches.
You don't know who can stand on their own two feet.
It's only when you start knocking crutches out that you find out who can stand.
It's that anthropomorphizing,
yes,
absolutely.
Animals that we wanted.
We wouldn't do that with people.
Of course we wouldn't do it with people,
but
these are animals and this is the natural world and this is why animals survive
and if you don't do that,
they won't survive.
Then you'll have the weak ones breed and develop all sorts of huge issues which
could be argued essentially that that's happening with people,
but people have a lot of other things to offer.
Our innovation,
our creativity and our ability to communicate and our thinking,
our what makes us uniquely human.
The animals,
it's.
It's simply their body,
their life,
their,
their existence and the way they interact with their knee,
with nature.
When when you tamper with that,
when you tamper with that,
you're.
You're essentially.
You're pretending you're smarter than nature itself and that's ridiculous.
We can't.
We can show real clearly by what you've said today about factory farming,
about the development of these diseases that we're not smarter than nature.
We don't and then we.
There's no one could know everything and there's not one person that's smart
enough to be able to see the whole big picture.
We need a lot of other eyes on this and we need a lot of other thoughts on this
and when you start applying the same sort of compassion and that,
that we rightly due to human beings,
you start applying them to animals.
You actually wind up screwing the animals.
Okay.
All over.
Yeah.
You,
you create a artificial fragility.
No Sir.
Albert Howard,
who of course,
you know,
develop the scientific aerobic composting process in which it,
his book is still kind of the icon of the whole sustainable agriculture
community.
It was written in 1943 and agricultural testament.
He says in there that when you,
when you use artificial artificial matures in the soil and that's what he called
a chemical fertilizers,
artificial manures.
It makes grows artificial plants which make artificial animals,
which then make artificial people who can only stay alive using artificials.
That was in 1943.
Wow.
Wasn't that present?
Yeah.
That comes on the ball.
That was just coming out.
I mean,
how long had factory farming even been around that?
It wasn't,
and we were just,
I mean that was 19,
43.
We were just really beginning to start using chemical fertilizers at that point.
Now when they have the issue with large scale agriculture,
when they chew up all the minerals in the ground and they have to add minerals
when they'd go over the top soil of American farmlands.
I mean,
they,
there was a paper that was written about it.
God,
I can't remember the year,
but it was a long time ago,
I believe it was in the 19 forties,
about the mineral deficiencies of topsoil,
of topsoil.
Um,
what,
what do they do about that now?
And it,
does that same issue still happen?
A farm like yours?
Well,
uh,
yes,
absolutely.
I mean,
mineral deficiency is a,
is a major problem in nature.
Fortunately a nature has a mechanism to remedy it.
Um,
you know,
amazingly it's onsite doesn't need a bunch of stuff brought in.
And the way nature remedies is with an act of decomposition cycle,
the way it works is when organic matter decomposes into the soil,
it gives off,
it exudes carbon dioxide when things rot,
they give off carbon dioxide.
And so that carbon dioxide as it,
as it percolates up through the pores in the soil,
you know,
the aggregates in the soil.
If you look at the soil and an electron microscope,
it really looks like a marsh,
you know,
there's all these little cavities and aggregates and moisture and all these,
slogging weird looking,
you know,
bugs and cal looking things and predators and herbivores.
And uh,
it,
it's,
it's an entire,
you know,
there,
there are more living beings and a double handful of healthy soil than there are
people on the face of the earth.
Whoa.
That,
that's how alive it is.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So,
so when that,
when that car,
when that carbon dioxide eases up through the,
through the aggregates in this,
in this kind of marshy soil,
it encounters h,
two o water,
alright,
in those aggregates.
And when the CEO,
two hits H,
two o it makes carbonic acid.
Now,
carbonic acid.
Uh,
if,
uh,
if we took,
if we said that this is a rock right here and we want to find out how much zinc,
cobalt,
molybdenum,
no aluminum,
whatever is in this rock,
we could treat it with lots of reagents.
We could use sulfuric acid,
hydrochloric acid,
you know,
we could use lots of different acids.
Guess which one is the most efficient asset to use?
Carbonic acid.
So,
so nature,
you know,
so,
so creation has this wonderful ability if there is,
if there is carbon decomposing in the soil
and moisture,
that creates a carbonic acid to break out the minerals that are in the parent
rock material in the soil.
If I went out,
if I went outside the studio here and picked up a rock and brought it in and
said,
is that rock?
Does it contain the same minerals?
And I mean,
is it,
is it the same thing as it was 2000 years ago?
You'd say yes.
I mean that's the rock.
I mean it's,
you know,
there's not a big hole through it.
You know,
yeah,
that's,
that's the way it was.
And,
and so we have plenty of parent mineral in,
you know,
out here.
The problem is we don't have an active decomposition cycle.
How do you,
how do you destroy a decomposition cycle?
You do it when you don't feed this when you don't have a carbon,
a carbon centric system.
And everything about modern farming is trying to get rid of carbon.
We,
this is one of the things that we're looking at.
Maybe if you've read the book called Wheat Belly,
um,
about,
you know,
gluten and,
and those sorts of things is that you used to be a win.
Our grand puppies,
we're planting wheat.
Wheat would grow,
um,
you know,
six feet tall.
It was real,
real tall so that the,
the grain to stem ratio was whatever it was,
you know,
the ratio.
Well,
the taller the wheat,
the taller the stalk,
the less weight it can hold out there,
you know,
it,
it wants to fall over,
you know,
because you go,
the skyscraper gets taller and Taller,
right?
And so in genetics and genetic breeding and selection,
what we've done in the last 50 years is shortened,
is selected shorter and shorter and shorter and shorter cultivars down to where
it's a very short stem and that ratio has fundamentally changed,
which also affects the enzymes and the nutrient components of those seed heads.
But we can combine it faster and we can grow a bigger head on a smaller plant.
But guess what we also did,
we also deprived the soil of the carbon that the straw and the stock would
produce from a given amount of grain that deprive the soil of the carbon
injection that was supposed to come when we took the grain head off.
And now we don't have that carbon decomposition cycle.
Wow.
And so the solution to that in the industrial way,
it's just admin
admin or you know,
mine mineral somewhere else and,
and uh,
and add them.
But all that can be done in house.
It can absolutely can all be done in house.
The wheat issue is,
is a big one with the Americans today.
Everyone wants to be gluten free and I'm guilty of it too.
I stopped eating gluten reading recently and I found that almost immediately,
like I felt more,
I felt less bloated after a meal,
if that's a good term,
less dated after a meal.
I just,
I didn't feel so tired.
And uh,
when I started reading about it,
I read that when we had been changed to,
uh,
to change the size of it,
to make it more hardy,
it also became more difficult to digest.
Yes,
absolutely.
Is it possible to get that old wheat back?
Absolutely.
There are people doing it right now.
I mean,
now Washington state,
the old red,
red rife a heritage varieties.
Absolutely.
You can,
they're there.
They're available.
You can buy them.
Yeah.
So how do you,
uh,
get bread?
That's that?
Well,
you,
uh,
I mean,
you can have your own flour mill if you want to buy it by the bag.
That sounds like a pain in the ass,
you know,
that that's where modern times are really exciting because we now have techno
glitzy gadgets in our kitchens.
Uh,
when people ask me,
you know,
what's,
what's the most important thing a person can do to advance the integrity food
movement?
My first answer is get in your kitchen.
And I'm not talking about hoop skirts.
Hearth cooking,
washboards,
barefoot,
pregnant in the kitchen.
Uh,
I'm talking about embracing techno glitzy gadgetry that we have today.
The kitchens we have today are not grandma's kitchens,
you know,
I mean,
we've got,
we've got two faucets with running water,
you know,
one's hot,
one's cold.
Uh,
I mean,
we've got ovens,
we've got refrigeration,
we've got stainless steel,
we've got Queensland Arts,
we've got blenders and,
and cool little,
you know,
um,
uh,
you know,
mills and flour mills and stuff.
And so,
um,
so,
you know,
uh,
when,
when we buy,
we buy 25 pounds a week of a flower at a time and a,
you can absolutely get it,
you know,
as bulk and you can use this gadgetry and grind it up and bake your own bread
and in,
in a,
in a computerized breadmaker wow.
God won't never had it so well,
it's never been easier to actually eat well than today ever.
That's interesting.
That's so true.
Well,
if you have the money,
right,
that's the big knock on organic food,
you know,
that,
most people don't have the money
to go to whole foods or oral,
that'd be addressed the money.
The way to address the money is to eat whole foods,
not processed foods.
You,
I'm sure you're familiar with the movie food inc.
And of course,
you know,
as a powerful movie a very profound.
But there's A real weakness in that movie where that,
you know,
that family that goes to burger king and they bow that,
they buy a whopper or whatever they get and they buy a it look,
it looks like a,
like a,
you know,
200 outside soft drink,
but you know,
whatever it is,
it's a big one and french fries.
And then they say they can't afford to buy produce vegetables.
The fact is that meal,
uh,
you know,
I don't,
I don't eat at burger king,
but anyway,
they're all the same.
Um,
that meal costs no more than two whole pounds of our polyface grass fattened
grass finished worldclass ground beef.
And there's more nutrition in half a pound of my ground beef than there is in
that entire meal fast food meal.
So when somebody says they can't afford it,
the first thing I do is I want to grab him.
I said,
okay,
let's go to your house and here's what.
We're not going to find it.
We're not going to find any fast food boxes or fast food receipts.
We're not going to find soda,
alcohol,
tobacco,
coffee,
widescreen tvs.
We're not going to find $100 designer jeans with holes already in the knees.
We're not going to find a know netflix,
people magazine,
you name your thing.
Um,
I'm,
you know,
I'm a lottery tickets.
That's a big one.
Okay?
You show me the house that doesn't have any of those things.
And then let's talk about price.
Talk about what you actually can afford.
Talk about what you want to you.
Actually,
because my position is we choose even even 95 percent of poor people still have
most of those things.
We choose what we're willing to buy.
You can buy wheat by the bushel,
you can make,
you can make $800 worth of bread from a $6 bushel of wheat.
What it means is you have to participate in the food system.
This,
this is our proBlem is not that it's not available or we can't get it or we
don't know what to do.
Our problem is that we want convenience.
We don't want to have to think.
We don't have to.
We don't want to have to plan ahead.
We don't have to want to plan menus.
We,
we want to just a convenient spontaneity and you cannot have an integrity
economic sector of anything.
Automobiles,
food,
clothes,
entertainment.
You cannot have an integrity,
economic sector of anything when you so profoundly abdicate personal
participation in that economic sector.
It is more expensive when you go to a supermarket and you buy organic
vegetables.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
it is.
It is.
And some of the better.
They are better.
Yeah.
Are they better scientific?
Well,
let,
let me say this.
I'm a,
I don't want to get,
you know,
crossways of,
of every.
Well,
I guess I might as well.
I might as well get crossways with everything out there.
Um,
in my view,
you know,
we should just not eat from the supermarket.
Don't eat from superman.
No.
Where do you get your food?
Oh,
you get it.
You get it from farmer's market.
You get it from a community supported agriculture,
food buying club of metropolitan food club.
You go to go to farmers,
buy bulk.
I mean the way to deal with the prices by it unprocessed and by volume,
which means that you have to recreate your domestic larder.
You know,
we don't even use that word anymore.
Larder,
who's ever heard that word,
but that's where all the food was eight years ago.
If I came to la and said,
where's the food in la?
It's not in a warehouse.
It would be an individual larders in houses.
And so when you buy in bulk
and you buy unprocessed and you put your sweat equity into preparing,
processing,
preserving and packaging,
then you can actually save money over the process counterpart.
That's incredible.
In other words,
you can get,
you can get top of the line.
I'm a local,
the best stuff in the world that's cheaper than the processed stuff in the
supermarket.
I went to,
um,
the green markets in New York city,
arguably the most expensive farmer's market in the country.
I asked my hostess,
I said,
would you do something for me?
Could you take me to the vendor with the most expensive potato in America?
So she,
oh,
I know exactly who we needed to go to.
So we went down to the stalls there and there was a vendor there that had about
20 varieties of potatoes.
They were beautiful.
He had them in little little,
uh,
you know,
box cubbies known as beautiful wooden slanted display.
There were red ones and yellow ones and green ones and blue ones and all this.
So I looked through the boxes and I found the most expensive one.
It was a,
it was a little a heirloom,
peruvian blue fingerling potatoes for $2 a pound.
That's expensive for a potato.
But you know,
you know what,
you know where most potatoes,
how much space was being sold in New York city.
$4 a pound as potato chips.
Hmm.
We've got queensland arch,
we've got slicers,
deisseroth,
and fry babies.
You can get the most expensive potato in America and it's half the price to
potato chips.
Potato chips is not food.
I mean it is,
but it's not.
I mean it's a snack and people pay for convenience and you get a real honest to
goodness potato and slice it yourself and fried in lard.
A frog baby.
That is food.
It is food.
But what I'm saying is most people when they get it,
they get it as a snack and they don't have the time.
When someone buys a bag of chips,
they're not going to go to the store and get a potato and slice it.
And in this modern world that we live in,
I'm saying I know in this modern world,
so we should essentially go direct to farmers and go to farmer's markets
whenever possible and you save a ton of money,
save a ton of money.
Mother earth news.
This issue actually has a,
um,
a big spreadsheet where they did exactly that.
They have a whole bunch of items that they bought at the supermarket,
at the farmer's market.
And,
and,
um,
I guess csh or something.
Anyway,
it is profound.
The savings going direct to farmers,
uh,
can create.
It's amazing and buying volume and,
um,
you know,
and taking,
taking the middleman out of it.
That's the thing.
Is it possible with your methods and the way that you're describing a farming
and what you've done with your farm,
is it possible to feed this entire country that way?
Oh,
no question.
Not only is it,
is it possible?
It's actually the only regenerative way to do it because when you break apart
the,
when you break apart the feed from the animal,
from the manure,
and we could even include people in that as well when you break all those,
those,
those that are supposed to be a synergistic blessings when you break them apart,
the whole thing floats on a counterfeit,
cheap energy,
cheap oil
and um,
and uh,
a fragile house of cards that depends on,
you know,
clever pharmaceuticals staying,
one mutation ahead of the,
of the mutating bugs to,
to,
to function.
So the argument against what you're prescribing in describing is that what you
have is sort of a,
a,
a beautiful small business model for creating a very ethical farm and raising
animals in a very nice way,
but it's impractical when you're talking about feeding a nation of 300 million
people,
but when,
but you're saying that not just the fact that you factor in when you farm your
way,
the lack of sort of invisible costs that you get with factory farming,
the lack of all the other factors that you have to bring in like chemicals and
antibiotics and all these different things that are just unnecessary completely.
But the actual volume of food,
the actual,
all you have a food.
Absolutely.
The actual volume of food is more in symbiotic places.
Let,
let me,
uh,
and,
and are kind of farming with portable infrastructure allows you to use nooks and
crannies that currently aren't being used.
Let me give you an example.
Let's take pigs as an example.
We run pigs in the,
in the woods,
and they eat acorns and bugs and weeds and things like that through the woods.
And they actually eat the bugs that would attack the trees in the woods of the
trees are healthier.
The fact is that we have millions and millions of acres of unused land.
There's not one reason for a single confinement hog facility in the entire
country.
If we used our national forests are bureau land management,
you know,
pinyon pine in Colorado,
if we use mesquite in Texas,
um,
you know,
appalachian hardwoods in,
in the mid atlantic and south every place has millions of acres where these pigs
could be run and it does.
And you simply vacate the houses.
So,
um,
so the,
the truth is we are,
we are not beginning to leverage.
We're not beginning to leverage the resource base that we have.
So when you're talking about is the resources that are untouched?
Yes.
So the factory farm system that we have,
the amount of food that they produce in order to produce that same amount of
fruit,
we would have to use more land.
We would have to use more areas that we're not using now.
We would have to.
Yeah.
But it would be good land use.
It's not,
it's not harmful land use,
I understand,
but that land is most likely either owned by the state national wildlife problem
too.
Well,
yeah.
And then the other problem would be where would the profit be?
Who would profit than if you're talking about national forests and you're
talking about a private company that grows agricultural,
gross farm animals in these natural forest who would be able to decide who gets
to use their animals.
And this.
Right.
Well,
when,
uh,
when governor tim kaine came to visit our farm toward the end of his governance,
the gubernatorial time in Virginia,
um,
he really got it.
I mean,
we went,
did all this,
you know,
saw this and he,
he totally,
he totally bought into it.
He said,
so,
um,
you know,
what,
what can I,
do you know,
what,
what's the next step?
I said,
well,
governor,
I said,
let's have a meeting next week at the,
at,
at the governor's mansion and iron out a lease arrangement where polyface can,
can run pigs in the state forests and keep all the trees from dying.
And of course,
you know,
he smiled and he knew,
he knew sarah burley that I was exactly right because the appalachian hardwood
forests are dying and they're due to lack of disturbance,
lack of disturbance in our ecosystem.
We don't have the buFfalo,
we don't have the fires anymore,
so they're dying due to lack of disturbance so we can absolutely bring those
forest back to vibrancy.
Right now they're just sterile,
they're just,
they're just sitting there so they could be disturbed by these disturbance.
And so,
so his,
his understanding of ecology,
absolutely.
I'm mandated that he get his head around this idea.
But of course he grinned and laughed at and we both realized,
I mean,
can you imagine what the radical environmental groups would do if you said,
we're going to start leasing some of the state parks so people can grow pigs in
them?
I mean,
it would be.
Well,
I mean it's unspeakable.
let's
forget about their arguments against an environmental groups or peta or anybody
who might have an argument against it.
If you have a clean slate,
and if it was your job,
you could design the,
uh,
the whole agricultural system of this country to feed America.
Yes.
Based on your principles,
easy.
No,
no question.
But we would have to use a lot of the land that's currently state land or
national forest.
Do you know that right now the us has 700 registered dead zones,
right?
Perry dead zones.
One is the size of New Jersey in the gulf of Mexico.
Those dead zones are collateral.
They are now.
They are now inhospitable to life.
I mean,
that's the,
that's the definition of a dead zone.
They are,
they were once productive areas,
you know,
fisheries and amphibians,
productive areas that are now inhospitable to life.
They are a direct result of overrunning our nests ability to handle our,
um,
our mechanistic creativity.
And so the fact is that in North Carolina,
which leads the state in hog production,
if you didn't have a hurricane every two years to flush all the manure lagoons
out to the ocean,
North Carolina would now be buried in hog manure.
That's the truth.
And so fortunately we,
fortunately,
you know,
we get a hurricane every couple of years,
tough flush North Carolina,
like a big toilet,
so it doesn't,
you know,
choke on its own waste.
Wow.
So,
so,
you know,
so The idea,
whose land are we using here?
Let's talk to the,
let's talk to the displaced a shrimp fishermen in the gulf of Mexico and talk
about displacement.
Let's talk about land use.
Are you with me when we start talking about the whole,
the,
the whole,
uh,
um,
land use issue.
Our system actually actually
would eliminate all of this dead zone,
all of this inhospitable,
the desertification,
all the collateral damage.
We would actually have far more productive land than we do today because we're,
we're toxifying a very small part.
And,
and,
um,
what,
you know that that toxic stream is killing a bunch of other land.
Why don't we just be honest and say,
let's use It all in a healing fashion and we will have any dead zones and it'll
all be,
uh,
you know,
progressively healing.
that sounds like a better alternative to me.
So the only way to have
these healthy environments,
these healthy growIng environments,
is to have sort of a symbiotic relationship with all the various different types
of animals and the various different types of plants.
Is it possible to have acres and acres of things like corn and wheat without
animals roaming free and still have some sort of a healthy environment?
I mean,
can you grow a thousand acres of corn in a healthy way without having animals
and the environment?
Um,
probably the short answer is no,
but if you.
But,
but that doesn't mean you can't grow grain.
I mean,
there are now,
uh,
in Australia,
um,
they're really colin seis there who has visited a term called pasture cropping,
uh,
has developed infrastructure and protocols for where you grow grain in perennial
pasture,
uh,
without,
without much tillage.
So you don't,
you don't till the,
uh,
the Blanket,
you don't till the vegetative blanket of the soil.
Instead you use livestock as a,
as a pruner to prepare a and even temporarily weaken the perennial grass plant
right into it.
The annuals,
barley,
wheat,
rye,
whatever,
and it grows.
Beats out the grass,
the grass days,
subordinated it in the shadow so that when the grain dries down,
you harvest the grain and you've already got a nice,
you Know,
a regrowth of a green material underneath with,
without ever actually destroying the sod.
And uh,
that's been there now,
2000 farmers in Australia doing this.
It's jumping now to the us.
It's a real hot technology and it works.
So,
you know,
there are a lot of pieces to this.
First of all,
if you quit feeding herbivores grain,
you tremendously reduce the amount of grain it has to be produced.
Then you go to a very good point.
That's a very,
very good point.
Then you go to a perennial and,
and uh,
you know,
at the top of the program we talked about these principles of nature,
one is animals move,
another is that nature.
A natUre likes perennials.
Nature has very few annuals.
Actually,
nature thrives on perennials.
So a,
a productive regenerative food system should be concentrated on perennials,
not annual.
So describe to people that don't know what the difference between those
perennial is a plant,
you don't have to plant every year.
An annual is a plan.
You have to plan annually.
Okay.
Every year.
So,
so grains,
um,
squash plants,
your garden vegetables,
those are annuals.
Blackberries are perennials,
you know,
you plant them once you trees are perennials,
vines,
bushes,
grasses.
Okay.
those are all perennials.
And so that is the basis of the,
of nature's ecology is perennials.
Not annuals.
Realized that our ag policy in the United States is to subsidize,
not perennials,
but annuals.
Six of them,
you know,
we corn,
soybeans,
cotton,
sugar and rice,
all of those are annuals.
So our official ag incentivization is to incentivize the very thing that
destroys soil.
That's hilarious.
And it's also hilarious that we insist on feeding animals grains just to get
them fatter.
Right?
And you know,
that fat being an unhealthy fat.
I am amazed every time I go to a nice restaurant and they try to offer me that
coby beef stuff.
Oh yeah.
I'm like,
well,
you'd get away from me with that sick cow thing is sick.
Oh,
it's so it's wonderfully marbled.
No,
that thing's dying.
Things barely alive when you shoot it.
Yeah,
that's right.
The liver livers probably swollen up.
So the point is that if we quit feeding herbivores grain,
we would,
we would grow way less than if we take the omnivores,
the pigs and the chickens and integrate them as salvagers.
Like
listen,
if every kitchen had enough chickens to eat,
it's kitchen scraps.
I mean,
you know,
like get rid of the pet dog and put it into two chickens.
Right.
Okay.
If every kitchen had enough chickens to eat the kitchen scraps,
there would not be an egg industry in the us.
Not one.
Okay.
This was the role of chickens.
What we do instead is we,
we send our,
our kitchen waste down the disposal or out in the garbage.
It goes to the landfill and the whole ecosystem is deprived of the,
of the biomass that's to compost or digest and feed the next cycle of life.
The problem is,
is really tough to keep two chickens in an apartment,
eh?
They don't take any more room than a quarter.
Then an aquarium or a durable to chickens?
Yeah.
well they gotta rhonda wouldn't the whole idea.
They have to wander around.
They don't need a lot of growth room.
I mean if you,
if you had them,
uh,
three feet by two feet would be fine for two chickens.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
But what about foraging and all that good stuff.
Just just,
um,
just,
you know,
built,
build your box,
your container so that they can,
um,
you know,
so that they can get to about 12 inches of compost underneath them and you just
throw your scraps in there and they.
And in the compost,
you know,
feed your little pot garden.
I mean,
well,
you know,
whatever kind of pot garden you have,
container gardens,
containers,
containers yet.
but,
but I'm happy with pop gardens too.
I mean take that whichever way you want to do it.
All right.
Anyway,
that becomes,
that becomes your,
you know,
your,
your fertilizer for your house.
And what you do then is you turn your house instead of an ecological liability.
Your house becomes an integrated part of an ecosystem asset.
Well,
it seems that in in that sense,
that giant cities like New York where people are stacked on top of each other,
they essentially a factory farming humans.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
They are a.
But there's.
There are a lot of these cool ways now that we can.
You know,
we can do it anyway.
If you take the pig and the chicken and you use them as their salvage operation,
then you cut even more grain,
so you take off the herbivore grain,
you take off the the chicken grain and the pig grain.
Suddenly
you don't have much grain use and when you don't need very much grain,
you don't have to plow very much.
You don't have to plow very much.
Then you can go back to a perennially based system and you can go back to the
historic rotations were several years of perennials built the fertility for the
one or two years of annual extraction.
Okay,
now now you're on to a regenerating an actual healing soil building system.
So what you're
bing or describing in fact is the way that our culture should have been
engineered in the first place.
But a lot of what we have here is sort of the momentum of the past that we have
to deal with the momentum of this factory farm establishment that was set up
that's been providing us with food for decades upon decades upon decades.
Almost a century now.
Yeah.
And you have to understand in context,
don't be too hard on the ancestors because it what,
what happened was it got easier.
It got easier to grow
and feed it.
That was,
that came earlier than electric fence and scientific composting systems.
So it was the electric fence that allowed us to suddenly I'm,
I'm free,
free these animals from supposedly a efficient confinement programs and grain
feeding programs.
It was the,
I mean,
George Washington at mount vernon,
he always complained about the pigs.
He was a very meticulous record keeper and he always complained about the pigs
because he could never get them all in at once,
you know,
because he just ran through the woods and they had their babies and you know,
you kinda.
Well it's hog killing time.
It's fall,
you know,
let's get what we can.
And a,
they'd get what they can never get them all.
So you never really knew,
you know,
for,
for a meticulous record keeper.
This was a nightmare,
right.
You know,
you never could count all of his stock and um,
but,
but that's the way pigs were used.
Pigs were just kind of,
they were just,
they were salvagers,
they were kind of nook and cranny,
you know,
operating weren't fenced in.
No,
they weren't fenced in because there was no fence that would keep them in.
How in the world can you ever fence a pig in with a physical structure?
Even,
I mean,
this is before,
before a metal wire,
you know,
the only fence they had were like,
uh,
rick's of,
of um,
you know,
you've seen them around museums and stuff,
little,
you know,
a chestnut rail fences will,
a pig would tear that apart in a hurry.
So what they did,
they,
they farmed,
they had an agriculture that was primarily exclusionary rather than
inclusionary.
So instead of,
instead of having,
I mean,
Thomas Jefferson wrote about this at marcelo in his farm book,
he had several slave boys that their job was to keep the livestock out of the
gardens.
So,
so the idea was that the livestock basically,
you know,
ran free maybe,
maybe with a herder or something or you know,
there were some fields but not that many.
And then what you did is you protected your,
you know,
your,
your garden,
you protected your berries and you're,
you know,
you're really high value stuff.
You protected that physically or with a fence,
some sort of a barricade because you simply couldn't afford to fence all the
animals and control them.
So,
so it became,
it became a lot easier to um,
to grow animals faster with grain than it did with controlled grazing because
you couldn't control the grazing.
So now the technology of electric fencing and,
and uh,
and composting has enabled us to bring the perennial pasture based model onto a
par with the grain model.
And the beauty of that is that the pasture based on non tillage model is an alt
is it's a soil building engine as opposed to tillage was s,
which is a soil destroying engine.
And so,
so all of this,
you know,
all of this has to be viewed in context and you have to,
you have to appreciate,
uh,
I tell people you don't crucify grandpa,
you know,
he,
he was trying to do what he did,
but uh,
but there's no excuse today for continuing grandpa's situation because we don't
have,
we've got grant things that grandpa would have gIven.
Is it to have today?
Yeah.
I think as we were saying before,
they were on the momentum of this past that was set up that couldn't also,
probably couldn't possIbly have anticipated the amount of population growth that
we have today.
That's very possible when you look at our future as a,
as a country and feeding us.
Do you have hope?
Do you,
do you think that people are coming around?
People are certainly more aware where their food comes from now than ever
before.
Do you see changes on the horizon?
I sure do,
and I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a pretty incorrigible optimist.
Uh,
overall I don't think though that the changes will be gentle.
You have to understand if what I've described in this program became normal,
it would completely invert the power position,
prestige and profit of the entire food and farming industry.
That's a big ship to turn around and they're not going to go gently into the
night.
And so that's why we're seeing the backlash of the swat teams,
you know,
coming in,
raiding people's freezers,
private food clubs,
we're seeing an increasing backlash.
The,
the food safety modernization act,
uh,
you know,
proposed that a,
you basically couldn't use compost to fertilize vegetables.
Uh,
we can't have animals and produce on the same farm.
We're going to outlaw of outdoor flocks of 3000 chickens are more,
uh,
I mean there's,
there's a,
there's a huge pushback from,
from that orthodoxy.
And um,
and I generally,
you know,
if you studied collapser guns and germs or 14,
93 or whatever,
uh,
what you find is that major societal change generally doesn't happen.
You knoW,
people don't just wake up and say,
I think I want a different society know it usually follows some major,
major thing and uh,
I mean the transition from draft power to automobile was incredibly disturbing,
you know,
in America.
Uh,
and,
and I think that that if the industry.
Let me give you one more little story.
I spoke last week.
I'm getting ready to go to the Netherlands and do a week of seminars in the
Netherlands.
I spoke to their,
one of their top ag journalist this week did an interview by phone and he said
that the previous week he had just interviewed the ceo of syngenta,
which is the european counterpart of monsanto.
And several years ago they adopted a plan,
a,
a target that they Would increase productivity in grains,
the grains that they were working on by 20 percent,
by 20 slash 20,
20 percent by 2020.
Has a nice ring to it.
Well,
there are several years into that plan.
He said,
for the last 15 years,
it's been totally flat.
Nothing we can do,
nothing we can invent.
Nothing we can do has been able to change grain production at all for the last
15 years.
What we're seeing is what joel Arthur Barker said when he wrote the book
paradigms 40 years ago,
introduced the word to the world.
He said,
one of the axioms of paradigms is that just when they appear to have achieved
perfection,
they're on the brink of collapse and the industrial food system has promised
disease,
free famine,
free,
you know,
a
paradise,
and now with gmos and there,
there are a lot of people that are really pumped up on their hubris who have
bought into this notion that we're going to go into some paradise nirvana only
to find out,
oops,
I'm gmos are causing spontaneous abortions and infertility.
Oops.
Is that true?
I mean,
whereas evidence to don huber,
have him on your show.
A don.
He reads a professor in ameritas from purdue university and he's showing the
direct relationship between,
uh,
or,
or have Jeffrey Smith on a,
but the direct relationship between a glyphosate,
which is roundup,
which is,
which is the,
which is the herbicide that's now doubled in use since gmos came out.
That was the number one thing.
Um,
and,
and there are absolutely,
absolutely,
uh,
in the last year.
So we're,
we're in our 15th year with gmos.
Remember it took 14 years to establish the ddt relationship with infertile frogs
in an exit,
wouldn't hatch.
We're now 15 years.
Last year there were something like 74 studies around the world impugning not
only the claims,
but showing harmful side effects,
collateral damage of gmos.
the,
the idea that gmos are actually more productive is pretty much universally
debunk.
Now,
they simply have not shown a productivity increase.
And so what I'm getting at is that the industry has continued to peg a,
the future on this thing and present this,
this kind of,
uh,
um,
you know,
argument this face that all is well,
man,
we're,
we're getting ready to perfect everything.
It's going to be,
you know,
it's going to be a new day in the morning,
right?
And suddenly we see all these studies.
We see these direct science,
causal links,
collateral damage.
We see,
you know,
one in four pigs right now in the industry,
is dying from a viral.
We see these things.
We see,
you know,
a listeria campylobacter,
salmonella,
e cola,
all these new latin squiggly words,
you know,
food,
pathogens,
autism on the increase.
My take is that we are just about ready for nature to say,
you know,
you,
you have,
you have taken enough shortcuts.
Now I'm going to bat and,
and,
and it follows barker's idea that all paradigms at the point of perfection or on
the brink of collapse when they're presented as perfect,
that's when they're on the brink of collapse.
I hope
people are listening to you.
I know people in the podcast listening to you,
but I hope people out there in the world of agriculture are really are listening
to you.
I know you,
there's a lot of blowback a against you,
but I sure I,
I hope people are taking into consideration all these things that you're saying
is there's so much logic to your words and there's so much wisdom and so much
research done that it just,
it's,
um,
it's a very puzzling situation for someone like me who knows very little about
other than talking to you and reading and watching documentaries.
It's a,
it's a very strange time.
It is indeed.
And that's why I encourage people to,
um,
to take their recreation entertainment budget of time and time and money and,
and start to participate in the food system.
Go visit a couple of farmers.
You know,
every single community is surrounded by really integrity farmers now they're
everywhere.
They're everywhere.
There is not a community in,
in the country that is devoid of really high quality integrity food.
Many of them are wanting to farm full time,
you know,
and they need like 10 more customers or more customers to tip them over so they
don't have to commute to town with the town job to support their pharm
addiction.
I implore urban people,
you know,
go To one less moVie,
go to leSs whatever,
you know,
opera,
whatever,
um,
but,
but invest in this,
in this integrity food idea,
and you will hear farmers say the same things I'm saying they'll use
and you'll be able to see it with your eyes and you'll be able to,
you'll be able to taste,
see,
touch.
You Will essentially connect with your ecological umbilical and that's a good
place to be.
I love the term integrity food too.
That's a really is a great term.
Yeah.
I love that.
You throw that around and,
and I,
I think what you're offering a as far as advice is fantastic.
Encourage people to go to these farmer's markets,
connect to these people that are growing food in this way and I think people are
most certainly more aware now than ever of where their food's coming from.
The term organic.
We never even heard that a couple of decades ago when it comes to food,
which just didn't exist.
Nobody talked about it and we've talked about gmos.
Nobody talked about anything.
All the 14 plus years that we have had gmos have been this massive series of
debates and denials and you know,
but I think people are more aware of it than ever before and I think a lot of is
because of people like you.
So thank you very much and thanks for coming on here.
It was a really interesting conversation.
I've really,
really enjoyed it and I really appreciate all of your knowledge and the fact
that you,
you,
you express it with so much passion.
It was really fun.
Thank you.
It's been a privilege to be with you.
Please.
It's been an honor.
Joel saltz,
and please follow him on twitter.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Uh,
he is,
uh,
the author of give your book's out.
What are the names of your book?
Well,
there's nine of them right now,
but,
um,
the ones that,
that,
you know,
that people need to know about would be the folks.
This ain't normal.
Um,
as well as the sheer ecstasy of being a lunatic farmer.
perhaps my favorite is everything I want to do is illegal.
Holy cows in hog heaven.
Uh,
you can farm the entrepreneur's guide to start and succeed in a,
in your farming enterprise.
Uh,
the latest one is fields of farmers,
uh,
mentoring,
interning,
partnering and germinating tomorrow's farmers.
So,
um,
there's good stuff there.
Beautiful.
joel salitan,
ladies and gentlemenj,
o e l s a l a t I n on twitter.
Thank you very much sir.
Thanks also to our sponsors.
Thanks to lumosity.com.
Go to lumosity.com forward slash joe.
Click the start training button and a get your learn on folks.
Thanks also to stamps.com.
Go to stamps.com.
enter in the code word j r,
e and get your $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com.
Go to o,
n n I t use the codeword rogan and save 10 percent off any and all supplements.
Thursday night I will be at the fillmore,
the jackie gleason theater with tony hinchcliffe in miami beach,
miami beach,
miami,
somewhere in miami,
Florida.
I don't knoW exactly where it is,
but joe rogan.net.
Go there,
find all the dates and I'll see you guys soon.
Much love.